Es geht wieder los mit der Ligatour zu den europäischen Top-Ligen bei den Männern und gleich mit einer Neuerung. Heute haben wir mit dabei nicht nur die Serie A, nicht nur La Liga, sondern auch die Ehre die Vigie. Ich freue mich sehr auf Christian Bernhardt, Fabian Pakulat und Daniel Zander jetzt hier im Rasenfunk.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Ich hab drauf gewartet, wir haben drauf gewartet. Jetzt ist es endlich soweit. Wir sprechen wieder über den europäischen Topfußball. Schön, dass ihr hier seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass wir hier einen Neuzugang haben vom Team von Oranjefußball auf Twitter. Sehr empfehlenswerter Account. Kommt unbedingt mal zu Blue Sky, bitte. Daniel Zander ist hier. Hallo Daniel.
Moin moin, hallo.
Schön, dass du da bist. Freue mich sehr und es ist eine Ehre, dass wir dein Podcast-Debüt sind. Wirklich sehr, sehr cool. Und alles andere als Debitanten sind natürlich Fabian Pakulat. Servus Fabian.
Hallo, Buenos Dias.
Meine Güte, wie toll du klingst. Woran das nur liegen könnte.
Ich weiß es nicht, Max. Ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht gab es ein Upgrade. Ein Upgrade über den Sommer, aber wirklich. Und dann haben wir noch Christian Bernhard mit dabei, der auch fantastisch klingt.
Hallo Christian. Hallo Max, schön, dass es wieder losgeht.
Ich freue mich auch, dass es wieder losgeht. Falls ihr euch gewundert habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass wir jetzt erst mal nur drei Ligen machen. Es kann sein, dass die Premier League noch dazustößt. Die Ligue 1 hat es leider nicht geschafft und die neue Idee ist, und da freue ich mich dann auch auf Feedback von euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass wir immer mal wieder dann auffüllen. Und die Ehre, die Vigie ist eine, über die ich sowieso schon oft reden wollte und mir ist nämlich auch aufgefallen, Fabian und Christian, wie oft wir eigentlich über Spieler reden, die dorthin gewechselt sind oder von da gekommen sind. Dann dachte ich mir, ja komm, dann füllen wir hier mal auf und holen den Daniel mit rein. Loslegen werden wir jetzt heute allerdings mit der Serie A. Denn Christian, da hat sich jemand reingedrängelt fast schon. Also spätestens heute hätten wir anfangen müssen mit der Ligatur. Was ist da passiert?
Ja, aus Gründen würde ich sagen, definitiv. Also wir zeichnen jetzt am Donnerstag auf und am Mittwoch, also ja vor etwa 24 Stunden, hat sich die Roma entschieden, Daniela de Rossi zu entlassen, was schon ziemlich aus heiterem Himmel kam. Der Rossi war anscheinend schon um 7.30 Uhr morgen im Trainingsgelände, hat das Training vorbereitet. Dann wurde er eine halbe Stunde später in den oberen Stock zu den Friedkens, den Eigentümern beordert und die hatten dann die Nachricht, dass er das heutige Training dann nicht mehr vorbereitet. Um 8 Uhr? Genau, sehr früh. Ja, also ganz kurz die Fakten. De Rossi ist nicht mehr Roma Trainer. Nachfolger ist auch schon gefunden. Das ist Ivan Juric, ein alter Bekannter aus der Serie A, der die letzten drei Jahre Torino gecoacht hat. Da ist ein Vertrag da ausgelaufen war und der jetzt eben noch auf dem Markt war. Und genau, also die Roma hat sozusagen innerhalb eines Tages dann die Nachfolge auch schon geklärt. Aber ich würde sagen, da gibt es jetzt dann doch einiges zu besprechen. Denn der Vertrag mit Herrn De Rossi wurde erst vor wenigen Monaten langfristig verlängert. Und ja, wir haben jetzt vier Spieltage gespielt in der Serie A. Wenn man sich die Tabelle anschaut, die Roma hat dreimal unentschieden gespielt, einmal verloren, also steht mit drei Punkten da. Das war jetzt nicht, wie sie sich das vorgestellt haben. Am vergangenen Wochenende gab es einen 1-1 in Genua. Der Ausgleich fiel in der 96. sozusagen. Und dementsprechend ja, drei Punkte aus vier Spielen ist nicht das, was die Roma sich vorstellt. Aber ich muss sagen, nicht nur mich hat die Entlassung eben sehr überrascht, denn man kann der Rossi definitiv vorwerfen, dass eben die Abläufe jetzt am Anfang noch nicht so da waren, wie sie sich alle erwartet hatten. Aber das betrifft A, würde ich sagen mal viele Mannschaften. B hat er teilweise die meisten seiner Spieler im Transfermarkt erst nach dem dritten Spieltag bekommen, sprich zum Ende des Transfer-Fans. Also gerade wenn man die Abwehr schaut, Mats Hummels, Mario Hermoso, die kamen ja als vertragslose Spieler. Manu Kone, der aus Gladbach kam, der hat glaube ich noch am 31. oder am 1. September dann 10 Minuten gespielt, weil er halt gerade erst gekommen war. Also ja, die Ergebnisse sind nicht gut, aber trotzdem sehr überraschend. Und reiht sich so ein bisschen ein, mit Jose Mourinho wurde das ja ähnlich gemacht Anfang des Jahres. Da gab es meiner Meinung nach gute Gründe dafür, denn das hat es sich so langsam abgenutzt. Und die Roma war da schon während der Saison den Zielen hinterher. Und irgendwie hat sich dieser Mourinho-Fußball und die Roma irgendwie– ja, das Kapit, glaube ich, war zu Ende. Und dann hat der Rossi ja wirklich, dürfen wir nicht vergessen, das letzte halbe Jahr einen guten Job gemacht. Die Roma sogar noch mal Richtung Champions League-Plätze geführt, hat nicht ganz geklappt. Im Europa League-Halbfinale, das erinnern Sie vielleicht auch noch ein paar, haben Sie gegen Leverkusen gespielt. Nachdem Sie das Hinspiel zu Hause mit zwei Toren verloren hatten, waren Sie zehn Minuten vor Schluss im Rückspiel gegen die damals noch ungeschlagenen Leverkusen vor der Verlängerung. Also der Rossi hat das schon sehr ordentlich gemacht und jetzt dann eben Vertragsverlängerung und jetzt plötzlich das Aus. Ja, da waren die amerikanischen Eigentümer energisch am Werk.
Und ist ja auch bei den Fans sehr beliebt, ne? Der Rossi ist jetzt nicht...
Ja, wenn es Francesco Totti nicht gäbe, der Gott Nummer Eins in Rom ist, dann wäre Daniele der Rossi Gott Nummer Eins. Also der Rossi ist mit, ja, eine der prägendsten Figuren dieses Klubs und kleiner Vorausblick, am Wochenende spielt Roma zu Hause gegen Udinese. Da wird es ungemütlich werden im Stadion, denn die Fans haben schon angekündigt, dass sie das der Vereinsführung, die Art und Weise halt eben auch, ja, nicht durchgehen lassen werden. Also das Klima ist jetzt auch für Juric kein angenehmes, der kommt da jetzt rein und eben, wenn du eine Klublegende so entlässt, nach wie gesagt nur vier Spieltagen, dann ja, macht das das Klima drum herum auch nicht einfacher. Und noch ganz kurz, ich habe wirklich drei oder vier Spiele der Roma auch gesehen und ich finde ja, also es gibt ja Spiele manchmal und da waren viele Spiele dabei. Ich finde, es gibt sehr viele Spiele, wo oft nicht der Trainer der entscheidende Punkt ist. Und ich fand, die Roma hatte solche Spiele am Anfang der Saison. Nur zur Einordnung, in den ersten zwei Spieltagen, wo sie einen Punkt geholt haben, hatten sie vier Postentreffer, haben Riesendinger liegen gelassen, könnten schon in Kaljeri, wo sie mit 0-0 starten, da köpft Dorfbeck in der 80. aus 5 Metern an die Querlatte. Die muss er halt setzen, dann steht es 1-0, dann gewinnt sie das, dann starten sie mit drei Punkten, dann schaut das schon ganz anders aus. Dann hatten sie ein gutes Spiel gegen Juwe vor der Länderspielpause. Juwe damals ja noch so im Flow alles gewonnen. Und dann haben sie in Turin echt 0-0 geholt, gut mitgespielt. Ich fand sogar nach Punkten vielleicht der leichte Sieger gewesen. Und jetzt kassierst du halt im vierten Spiel, in der 96. den Ausgleich, wo du davor auch schon den Sack hättest zumachen können. Also was ich dir mit sagen will, ja, die Roma war noch nicht, hatte viele Baustellen noch, gar keine Frage. Aber in der Liga gibt es viele Clubs, die noch viele Baustellen haben, das auch daran liegt, dass eben der Transfermarkt so lange offen war. Und dann einen Trainer nach nur vier Spieltagen zu entlassen, wo auch die Spielsituationen sehr viele waren, wo nicht der Trainer derjenige war, sondern wo die Kollegen auf dem Feld das Ganze vielleicht hätten auch zu Ende spielen können. Wie gesagt, finde ich sehr ungemütlich. Man hat jetzt auch schon in Italien viel. Gasperini hat sich zum Beispiel gestern auf der Champions League Pressekonferenz dazu geäußert, gemeint, er war mega überrascht, dass er entlassen wurde. Klar, da muss man jetzt sagen, dass sicher oft die Solidarität unter Trainern spielt da eine Rolle, was ja auch ganz normal ist. Aber ja, das ist eine Entscheidung, die ich bin immer gespannt, ob die langfristig für die Roma dann halt auch Wirkung zeigen wird.
Vor allem weil die schnelle Nachfolgeregelung mit Ivan Juric, über den sollten wir gleich auch noch zwei Worte verlieren. Die hat ja zwei Dinge bewirkt. Das eine, und das wird euch ja auch gegangen sein, viel zu kurze Haltbarkeit von Edin Terzic kommt zu Mats Hummels in den Club Memes, die ich sehr witzig fand. Das warf ich ihm mindestens genauso vor, wie die Entlassung. Nein, natürlich Spaß. Aber zum anderen so gerät es natürlich, dass man sich mit diesem Szenario schon befasst hat. Und da muss man ja dann schon die Frage stellen nach allen Dingen, die du jetzt gesagt hast, was soll sich denn groß verändert haben seit Beginn der Saison, außer die Ergebnisse, die aber ja auch noch erklärbar sind. Man muss es ja als Alleingang oder Schnellschuss, vielleicht auch Overreaction der Eigentümer bezeichnen, wahrscheinlich Christian, oder?
Ja, definitiv. Also nur noch mal kurz zur Einordnung. Im Sommer ist bei der Roma sehr viel passiert, gerade personell. Die Roma hatte ja die vergangenen Jahre, hatten sie durch ein Financial Settlement Agreement mit der Waffa, hatten sie relativ wenig Spielraum auf dem Transfermarkt. Das ist Ende der letzten Saison ausgelaufen. Und jetzt eben in dem Sommer konnten sie wieder frei agieren und haben wirklich viel investiert, haben mehr als 100 Millionen Euro ausgegeben. Fabian Weiss, Sie haben Dolfbick, den La Liga-Torschützenkönig, geholt. Sie haben Suley geholt, argentinischer Nationalspieler. Sie haben im Mittelfeld jetzt Emanou Cunet geholt, was sich für einen Megastil halte. Ich glaube, den haben sie für unter 20 geholt, jetzt mittlerweile französischer Nationalspieler. Also der wird denen sehr, sehr gut tun. Ja, den hat der Rossi bis jetzt gefühlt in drei Trainingseinheiten gehabt. Dann haben sie in der Abwehr eben mit Hermoso, mit Hummels da auf dem Markt der freien losen Spieler wirklich noch viel Erfahrung dazu geholt. Aber wie gesagt, da kamen halt auch viele sehr spät. Und das alles zusammen zu mixen, ja, glaube ich, würde ich mal sagen, bedarf halt ein bisschen Zeit. Und dass sie die Zeit jetzt einem wie der Rossi überhaupt nicht gegeben haben, ist schon sehr, meiner Meinung nach, sehr, ja.
Dumm. Sagst du einfach.
Ja, dumm.
Gerade bei einer Mannschaft wie der Rossi, wenn er umstritten wäre, wie Borrigno, da konnte man es doch verstehen. Aber bei dieser Wahl, bei dieser Entscheidung ist doch völlig klar, wie die öffentliche Meinung ausfallen wird. Zumindest eben unter den Fans. Und dann machst du dir da einfach ein Thema auf.
Ja, du machst dir einen Riesenfass auf. Der Punkt ist jetzt, sie spielen jetzt am Wochenende gegen die Udinese. Da kommen wir später dazu. Die sind Tabellenführer. Die kommen also mit dem Lauf. Das wird also unangenehm. Dann fängt ja auch für die Roma die europäischen Wochen an mit der Europa League. Klar, auf dem Papier sitzt das Serie-Jahr-Spieltag. Die ersten nächsten Spiele vielleicht nicht die großen Namen. Aber genau das hättest du dir der Rossi auch zugesteben können. Dass du sagst, hey, jetzt hast du endlich mal alle an Bord. Jetzt arbeitest du weiter an deinen Ideen. Und dann schauen wir, dass wir halt wieder ins Fahrwasser zurückkommen. Und selbst, das muss man auch kurz einordnen, selbst die nur drei Punkte nach vier Spielen. Milan hat fünf Punkte, also ist nicht weit weg. Ja, und selbst Juve und Inter stehen bei acht. Ja, das ist mehr, aber das sind fünf Punkte. Also bei aller Liebe. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das Gefühl habe, die Roma ist schon komplett weg und dementsprechend, ja, ganz, ganz komisch. Und weil du es jetzt sagst, wir müssen jetzt kurz über Juric sprechen. Juric bin ich jetzt schon auch sehr gespannt. Klar, er hat den Vorteil, er kennt die Liga sehr gut. Das ist sicherlich ein Vorteil, den er auch gegenüber von der Rossi hat, dessen wirklich erste große Trainerstation das logischerweise war. Er hat Turino in den letzten Jahren da sehr stabilisiert, immer so auf neun und zehn einlaufen lassen. Und das ist halt für die Möglichkeiten von Turino, würde ich mal sagen, das Höchste der Gefühle, denn davor sind halt einfach die großen acht, die haben halt mehr Möglichkeiten. Letztes Jahr ist er sogar vor Napoli eingelaufen. Aber ja, Juric ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht einer, wo du sagst, okay, das ist jetzt der, der jetzt alle Herzen höher schlagen lässt. Und wenn man sich anschaut, er hat anscheinend einen Vertrag bekommen jetzt für diese Saison mit Option, falls sie in die Champions League kommen, dass es sich verlängert. Auf gut Deutsch signalisiert die Clubführung ja damit eigentlich auch schon, falls das mit Juric in dem Jahr nicht klappt, dann werden wir nächsten Sommer uns schon wieder umschauen. Und das ist halt etwas, was für mich sehr weit weg ist vom programmatischen Denken eines europäischen Top-Klubs.
Es wird nicht passieren, aber Jürgen Klopp bei der Roma wäre lecker.
Ich kann euch nur kurz sagen, der Name Sari ist auch gestern kurz durch die Gazetten gesagt. Ja, da haben dann vielleicht ein paar vergessen, dass der zuletzt Lazio trainiert hätte und ich möchte wirklich nicht wissen, wenn die Amerikaner jetzt Sari geholt hätten, was dann bei den Roma heimspielen würde.
Okay, also wir werden es beobachten. Das war auf jeden Fall etwas überraschender, würde ich sagen, diese Entscheidung. Ein bisschen weniger überraschend ist, dass wir, wenn wir jetzt über die Eredivisie sprechen, mal über Ajax sprechen, vor allem für diejenigen, die uns bei YouTube zu gucken, die nämlich sehen, Daniel, dass du über entsprechende Trikots hier aufgeschlagen bist. Das ist natürlich stark, wenn wir hier den Trikot Donnerstag immer ausrufen. Was gibt es denn bei Ajax zu berichten?
Ja, einiges. Während gestern die große Welt des Fußballs in der SCL gespielt hat, hat auch Ajax gespielt. Das hat mich immer so ein bisschen in den guten alten Zeiten, als auch Ajax international in der Tipp-Instieke treten war. Aber es war gestern Liga tatsächlich und das war schon ein bisschen besonders, denn der letzte Ligaspiel von Ajax war fast einen Monat her. Und in der Eredivisie gibt es im Prinzip gerade sehr viele Probleme wegen eines Polizeistreiks. Und die Polizei dort streikt für eine bessere Frühpensionierung. Und die Spiele, die bestreikt werden, sind aber jetzt immer Ajax-Spiele. Das war jetzt schon dreimal der Fall. Ausschließlich Ajax-Spiele bislang, genau. Und es war am dritten Spieltag gegen Fortuna Sittard. Das war das Spiel von gestern. Es war am vierten Spieltag gegen Feyernoord, der Klassiker, die natürlich auch sehr große Polizei und Unterstützung braucht, das Spiel. Und es war dann der Spieltag gegen Utrecht jetzt, das jetzt vor kurzem erst verlegt worden ist, wo auch noch nicht klar ist, wann das überhaupt ausgetragen wird. Und gestern war das 5 zu 0 von Ajax gegen Sittard. Und es war auch schön mal wieder ein Ligaspiel sehen zu können von Ajax tatsächlich. Und das Ganze hat aber auch einen sehr bitteren Nachgeschmack, ein Geschmäckle. Denn Martin Prink, das ist der Gewerkschaftler von der Polizei, der ist, könnte man schon sagen, PSV-Fan. Also auf Twitter gab es mittlerweile einige Tweets, die rausgeholt wurden, die entdeckt wurden, sind von einigen Fans, wie er durchaus chemisch über Ajax kommuniziert hat, wie er sich freut, wenn PSV punktet. Und das Ganze wurde ihm natürlich zum Verhängnis. Wenn dann auffällt, es sind drei Spieler von Ajax, die von der Polizei bestreikt wurden und alle anderen Partien konnten noch mal stattfinden. Und das Ganze ist so ein bisschen, wo war das Ajax, habe ich es mal so auch als Thema gesetzt und als Thema genannt, denn es ist noch nicht so klar, wo die Reise hingeht. In der vergangenen Saison gab es ja dieses desatröse Jahr für Ajax, wo man ja noch zwischenzeitlich als Letzter war. Es war eine historisch schlechte Saison von Ajax mit viel Umbruch, mit viel Lärm, mit einem Sven Mislentad und so weiter und so fort. Und man hat jetzt eigentlich so die Hoffnung gehabt, dass das in diese Saison in ruhigere Fahrwasser gerät. Mit dem neuen Trainer, mit Fahri Oli, mit vielen neuen Spielern. Er hat ja auch versucht, die ganzen Transfers von Sven Mislentad loszuwerden. Da ging dann zum Beispiel so ein Sosa jetzt auch nach Italien. Da ging jetzt auch ein Medec zu Bochum und so weiter und so fort. Und das Ganze ist aber jetzt auch schon wieder, würde ich sagen, sehr interessant, wenn die Reise geht. Allein schon wegen dieser Polizeistreitgeschichte hat Ajax jetzt drei Spiele und alle anderen haben fünf Spiele auf dem Konto, bis auf die Spiele, die die Vereine gegen Ajax hätte spielen müssen.
Aber weiß der PSV-Fan da in der Polizeigewerkschaft, dass sie ihre Spiele schon nachholen? Also er kann es nicht dafür den Abstift damit erzeugen. Das ist ja total absurd.
Er ist absurd, aber ich würde sagen, es führt trotzdem zu Problemen für Ajax. Die Spiele werden zwar nachgeholt, aber du hast jetzt A das Problem, dass du diesen Rhythmus nicht hast. Ich war auch sehr gespannt vor dem Spiel gegen Zitard, wie sich Ajax präsentiert, wenn du seit einem Monat kein Ligaspiel mehr hast. Und auf der anderen Seite bekommst du hinten noch Probleme, wenn dein Terminkalender dann relativ hintenaus voll wird. Das wird auch spannend. Ajax spielt international. Es wird spannend zu sehen, wann diese Nachos-Spiele in den Kalender kommen. Zwischen den anderen Ligaspielen, zwischen den internationalen Wettbewerben, zwischen dem Pokal, zwischen dem Baker. Das ist dann schon die Frage, wo die Reise hingeht. Allein deshalb schon. Und was auch zu beobachten ist, ist in dem Zusammenhang auch, wie sich das neue Team einspielt. Du hast sehr viele junge Spieler. Du hast aus Belgien einen Hroz, der vorne mittlerweile sogar Stamm spielt. Du hast hinten einen Harto. Du hast einen Taylor. Das sind alles sehr, sehr junge Leute. Die sind teilweise auch 18, 19 Jahre alt. Und hast dann hinten raus am Transferfenster, als man Bergwein endlich verkaufen konnte, für 21 Millionen waren es, glaube ich, dann noch einen Hroz geholt, einen Klaassen geholt, der bei Inter ja auch nicht mehr den Vertrag hatte. Und es ist eine spannende Mischung zwischen jung und aber auch sehr erfahren. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wie spielt sich das ein? Und wenn du das natürlich kaum spiele hast, wo du dich einspielen kannst, ist das natürlich, macht es den Weg nicht einfacher für Ajax letztendlich. Muss aber noch mal dazu sagen, abfließen, dass es gestern sehr überzeugend war. Auch mit ein bisschen Glück. Ich glaube, auch relativ früh eine rote Karte für Zidharth. Dann wurde es einfacher. Das stand aber auch schon 2-0. Und das war ein Spiel, wo Ajax wirklich mal über eine fast schon volle Dissenssouverän war. Also das letzte Ligaspiel vor einem Monat ging verloren gegen Preda, ein Aufsteiger mit 2 zu 1. Das war nicht so souverän. Aber das ist im Prinzip das Thema, was man im Auge behalten sollte. Was Ajax so macht.
Ja, und was der Polizeigewerkschaftspräsident da so macht. Grundsätzlich sind der Streiks immer gerechtfertigt. Es gibt immer einen Anlass dafür. Aber ob es dann wirklich immer nur die Spiele eines Vereins treffen muss? Nun ja, das wird sicherlich ja auch in den Niederlanden diskutiert werden. Eine Frage muss ich dir jetzt aber stellen, wenn ich dich jetzt schon hier habe. Ich habe das Spiel Deutschland gegen die Niederlande gesehen und ich war extrem überrascht vom Hinterteil vom Brobby, weil im Grunde dieses Spiel allein, dieses Körperteil alleine, wesentliche Teile des Spiels geprägt hat. Liegt es jetzt an mir, dass ich so überrascht war oder hat er da auch einen besonderen Sahnetag gehabt? Du hast ihn ja dann öfter gesehen.
Also, Brobby ist eine Figur, an der sich, glaube ich, viele Leute polarisieren. Also auch bei uns, auch bei uns im Team ist es so, er hat sich ja in Deutschland bei Leipzig nicht ganz toll setzen können, sage ich mal. Und ich würde sagen, er hat auf jeden Fall Potenzial. Und ich würde aber sagen, es war schon eher ein Sahnetag von ihm an diesem Abend tatsächlich. Ich erinnere an das Spiel gegen Penelty Neikos in der Quali jetzt von Ajax, wo er ja auch quasi extra nur für das Späterschießen eingewechselt worden ist und dann beide verhauen hat. Das ist dann auch mit tollen Teams, mit Flücksicherungen in Amsterdam, Schriebfohle-Wahnd, der baldest noch unterwegs. Ja, also er wird oft besichert, was dann aber zugleich dazu führt, dass seine Leistungen, die er dann auch bringt, dann oft so ein bisschen underrated sind. Aber ich würde sagen, das war schon ein Dane-Tag, aber es ist auch eine Figur, die sehr polarisiert.
Man kann sich sehr gut an ihm reiben und es ist ja klar, wenn er den Hintern immer so rausstellt. Ha, ha, ha, Entschuldigung. Ich muss auch noch erst auf Betriebstemperatur bekommen. Also das war unser Thema aus der Ehre die Vigie und dann kann ich Uli Hebel hier in der Runde begrüßen. Uli, schön, dass du da bist.
Freut mich auch, dass ich da sein darf. Grüß euch.
Ja, schön, dass du hier bist. Aber Nachzügler werden bestraft. Erst darf Fabian sein Thema machen und du das dann mit deinem Premier League Thema kommen. Ist mir doch egal, dass du gestern Champions League kommentiert hast. Fabian, was ist denn das, was wir aus der La Liga, aus den ersten Spieltagen unbedingt wissen müssen?
Ja, ich habe euch ein Team mitgebracht, das die letzten Wochen und auch Monaten sehr guten und sehr offensiv und sehr erfrischenden Fußball spielt und das ist Celta Vigo. Wir hatten es schon in der Ligatour letztes Jahr gesprochen, Ende des Jahres, glaube ich. Er hat ja im vergangenen Jahr das Zepter von Rafa Benitez übernommen, der im März entlassen worden ist nach chronischer Erfolglosigkeit, was so seine letzten Stationen allgemein widerspiegelt, wo Rafa Benitez überall noch im Einsatz war. Und Claudio Chiraldes hat dann übernommen, wie gesagt, der Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft, ein junger 36-jähriger Fußballlehrer und hat seitdem Celta Vigo, würde ich sagen, relativ progressiv nach oben geführt und spielt, wie gesagt, einen sehr herzerfrischenen Offensivfußball. Marke, würde ich jetzt sagen, um den Bundesliga-Vergleicher zu stellen, VfB Stuttgart. Die gewinnen öfter mal lieber 3-2 als 1-0 oder so in die Richtung. Und ja, macht dementsprechend wirklich sehr viel Spaß. Und sie stehen im Moment mit drei Siegen und zwei Niederlagen aus den ersten fünf Ligaspielen auf Tabellenplatz 5. Und ich habe ein sehr, sehr gutes Gefühl bei der Mannschaft, die eine sehr gute Mischung hat aus erfahrenen Leuten. Den einen oder anderen werden wir vielleicht gleich noch ansprechen. Und aus vielen jungen Leuten aus der eigenen Jugend, die natürlich Chirades mit hochgezogen hat, die kannt er ja alle. Und er rotiert extrem in diesen fünf Ligaspielen. Die waren ja alle sehr gepackt jetzt aufgrund der internationalen Wochenländerspielen und so weiter. Und es ist echt unglaublich, wie viele Positionen er schon ändern hat, müssen auch wegen Verletzungen. Und teilweise eben auch Mut dazu hatte, junge Spieler reinzuwerfen, die ihm normalerweise nicht enttäuscht haben. Und wie gesagt, Celta Vigo, Moment, Tabellen 5. Und macht unwahrscheinlich viel Spaß, den Jungs beim Kicken zuzusehen.
Aber junge spanische Spieler, können die was?
Ja, wenn sie nicht nach Saudi-Rahim gehen. Schon mit 20, 21 Jahren wieder so ein Spieler von Celta Vigo, das letztes Jahr gemacht hat. Nee, auf jeden Fall. Taktisch finde ich die immer, muss ich sagen, schon sehr gut ausgebildet. Und was mir vor allen Dingen bei Vigo gefällt, der Trainer vermittelt ihnen Mut, Mut ins Tripling zu gehen, Mut nach vorne zu gehen. Es ist ein unwahrscheinlich schnelles Umrisschaltspiel, was sie praktizieren. Bei Ballgewinn geht es eigentlich mit Vollgas nach vorne. Sie haben, wie gesagt, auch das nötige Spielermaterial. Wer gerade wieder in Form kommt nach, ich würde fast sagen zwei Jahren Krise, ist Borja Iglesias, der Stürmer, der auch bei Leverkusen letztes Jahr kurz mal zur Leih war, der ja auch mal spanischer Nationalspieler war, dann bei Bettis Probleme hatte im letzten Jahr in der Hinrunde, dann bei Leverkusen auch nicht wirklich groß zum Zug kam. Und der hat jetzt wieder ein bisschen das Vertrauen bekommen und hat schon dreimal geknipst dort vorne, fühlt sich auch wieder wohl. Er ist ja selbst Galizia, das heißt, er ist auch ein bisschen wieder zurück in der Heimat. Da kommt wieder diese ganze Bindung zusammen, es sind ja viele Galizia dann auch im Team, weil ja auch viele Jugendspieler da sind, also da ist ein ganz gutes Klima in der Hinsicht. Und da gibt es ein paar junge Wilde außen rum, wie zum Beispiel den Schwedens Wettberg, den ich sehr interessant finde, mit 20 Jahren. Der verballert zwar noch einige Dinge, einige hundertprozentige oder hochkaräter, aber man sieht, der Junge, der hat es drauf und da wird noch einiges passieren. Es gab am dritten Spieltag ein wunderbares Fußballspektakel, Villareal gegen Celta de Vigo, das Villareal mit 4 zu 3 gewonnen hat. Villareal ist gerade Tabellenvierter, die spielen so den ähnlichen Stil, haben aber nominell besseren Kader. Und dieses Spiel hätte auch 5 zu 5 ausgehen können oder 5 zu 6 für Vigo. Es war unglaublich, was die Mannschaften geboten haben. Nach dem 3 zu 3 ging es eigentlich nur noch hundertprozentig auf einer Seite, hundertprozentig auf andere. Da hat eben dieses Wettwerk schon ein paar verballert. Aber es macht einfach unwahrscheinlich Spaß, den Jungs beim Kicken zuzusehen. Und es ist halt eine schöne Geschichte, wenn man einen Trainer aus den eigenen Reihen hat, viele Spieler aus der eigenen Jugend hat und da ein schönes Gemengelage hinbekommt. Und einen Spieler würde ich noch ganz gern bei der Sache erwähnen. Der ist einst von Barcelona vom Hof nicht gejagt worden. Er ist mehr oder weniger auch freiwillig gegangen. Oskar Minguesa heißt er. Das ist der– ich mache wieder einen schönen Bundesliga-Vergleich– der Joshua Kimmich von Celta Vigo. Der ist eigentlich Rechtsverteidiger, spielt aber meistens in der Offensive dann doch eher die zentrale Mittelfeldposition, hat zwei Tore, Ziel, drei Vorlagen gegeben, ist an jeder guten Aktion beteiligt, dem gelingt alles. Der hat, glaube ich, in allen fünf Spielen bisher die, naja, nicht die Kickernote 1 bekommen, aber sehr, sehr gut benotet worden. Und weil er auch einfach im Moment in der Form seines Lebens ist, mit 25 Jahren, könnte er auch einer werden, wenn der so weiterspielt, der vielleicht wieder zurück auch in die Nationalmannschaft dadurch kommt.
Könnte er einer für Barca werden.
Und einer für Barca. Aber da ist es ja finanziell nicht ganz so einfach. Aber who knows.
Ja, genau. Und so wie ich gesehen habe, wie Uli genickt hat bei der Erwähnung von Oscar Minghezer, bin ich mir sicher, dass Uli bei einer seiner weitreichenden Streifzüge in der Vorbereitung auf irgendein Spiel über ihn schon gestolpert ist.
Ja, ich habe, glaube ich, die Debuts jeweils damals gemacht. Das war, glaube ich, in der Corona-Saison, als der durchbrach, in Anführungszeichen. Und da hat er mir eigentlich sehr, sehr gut gefallen. Und ich hatte den auch in einem Klassikoo. Das war, glaube ich, das beste Spiel seiner gesamten Karriere.
Okay, also Oscar Minghezer, den Namen merken wir uns. Bevor wir aber jetzt weitermachen, Fabian, habe ich noch eine Rückfrage, weil wir hatten das doch schon mal. Wir hatten doch schon mal Celta Vigo auf Platz 4 nach 12, 14, 16 Spieltagen, irgendwie so relativ weit in der Saison, vor zwei Jahren oder vor drei Jahren. Und dann kam aber die Regression zur Mitte. Was ist denn anders jetzt im Vergleich zu damals vielleicht?
Der Aufbau ist auf jeden Fall viel nachhaltiger. Der Mannschaft, der Kader an sich, ist wirklich sehr breit gestreut. Er rotiert viel, Trainer Chiraldes. Gibt also quasi jedem Spieler auch das Gefühl, wichtig zu sein. Gibt den Jungs Spiel an Einsatzzeit. Und ja, es ist einfach ein kleines Wohlfeelbecken im Moment für die Galizie, die eigentlich in den letzten Jahren auch mit dem Präsidenten es nicht immer ganz einfach hatten, die mit dem Stadion Probleme hatten, die institutionell eher auf schwierigeren Beinen gestanden sind oder nach wie vor ein bisschen wackelig stehen. Aber sie haben einfach einen unwahrscheinlich tollen Zusammensatz gefunden und einem Trainer, den sie folgen, der erst 36 ist, der selber mal gekickt hat, zwar nicht wirklich professionell, aber zumindest die Jugend von Real, die Jugend von Atletico Madrid durchlaufen hat und ja, einem, dem man einfach folgt, dem man an den Lippen legt und oder ja, und wie gesagt, es funktioniert eben gut, diese Mix, diese Mischung aus diesen jungen Talenten und den, ja, erfahrenen Spielern, die vielleicht nochmal ihr letztes, ihre letzte Chance suchen nochmal, ja, eben noch eine ganz gute Saison zu spielen. Genau. Man hat noch Iago Aspas, der ist inzwischen so ein 36, aber auch der oder 37 ist ein schön, aber der kann halt den Jungen unwahrscheinlich viel mitbringen. Der ist nach wie vor nicht in jedem Spiel in der Startelf, aber wenn er kommt, ist ja ganz klar, wie er das Spiel beleben kann, wie er das Spiel lesen kann, wie er Pässe stecken kann, wie er selber abschließen kann. Also da ist einfach ein guter Mix zusammen bei Vigo und ich bin mir sicher, Max, da leg ich mich jetzt mal fest, da kannst du mich Ende der Saison dann festnageln, dass selter Vigo nicht unten reinrutschen wird.
Stark. Ah, das ist wirklich die Geschichte, die sich jeder für seinen Verein wünscht. Du bist Jungespieler aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs, sind Trenner aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs und du hast noch diesen 37-jährigen Yago Aspas. Ich hab's nochmal gefaktcheckt, weil ich konnte das nicht glauben. Letztlich bedeutet das einfach nur, wie alt ich bin. Das Yago Aspas ist in meinen Augen immer Mitte 20 geblieben.
Sieht auch nach wie vor eher in die Richtung aus.
Okay, da liegt es ja nicht komplett an mir. Also, Zeltavigo, wir behalten es im Auge und wir merken uns deine Prognose. Die Hörerinnen und Hörer werden mich schon dran erinnern, irgendwann am Ende der Saison. Und dann wollen wir noch in die Premier League schauen, Oli. Wir haben ja bisher viele Überraschungen gehabt oder besondere Geschichten, die es an den ersten Spieltagen gab. Was hast du uns denn mitgebracht?
Ich muss ja ein bisschen umbauen jetzt. Das heißt, ich kann nicht mehr mit Groß und Klein kommen bei dir und mit Positiv und Negativ. Das heißt, ich mogel dir einen unter und fange mal an und sage, ich nenne das Thema Manchester City gegen die Welt, weil es auf der einen Seite impliziert, dass wir ein wenig über den Meisterschaftskampf, in Anführungszeichen, der ist ja noch nicht jetzt voll entbrannt, aber ein wenig darüber sprechen können. Und vor allen Dingen, ganz England spricht in dieser Woche selbstverständlich über die anfangende Anhörung hinsichtlich der potenziell 115 Vergehen Manchester Citys gegen die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln der Premier League. Währenddessen City aber das einzige Team ist, das noch perfekt ist, alle Punkte geholt hat und Erling Harland hat, der selbst für seine Verhältnisse nochmal anders raushaut im Moment. Und so sind irgendwie in England schon wieder alle der Meinung, dass jetzt eigentlich nur noch die Liga selbst helfen kann, weil ansonsten ist der Meister eigentlich schon wieder gekürzt.
Ja, also Erling Harland hat ja offensichtlich das Ziel, so viele Tore zu erzielen, wie Manchester City gegen die Nachhaltigkeit zu erzielen. Irgendwie 9 Tore von den 11, die sie geschossen haben? 2 Hat-Tricks, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe. Stimmt die Geschichte, dass auf dem letzten, also auf dem Hat-Trickball unterschreiben ja dann oft die Teamkameraden und stimmt es, dass da manche drauf geschrieben haben, ich habe da jetzt keine Lust mehr drauf und f**k auf und so weiter?
Ja, er selber auch. Er selber hat auch schon ein paar Mal geschrieben, immer das Gleiche.
Okay, hat sich denn da was verändert, dass Erling Haaland so gut ist? Vor allem, was ist das für eine Nachricht an die Liga? Denn ich erinnere mich, dass Jogi und auch du, ihr habt immer wieder gesagt, naja, also wenn es mal so eine Schwächephase bei City gibt, dann ist sie immer im Herbst und dann rollen sie durch.
Ich habe das auch wieder stehen bei meinen Saisonvorbereitungsunterlagen. Ich streichle sie jetzt aber, weil das ist, glaube ich, nicht mehr korrekt das zu sagen. Es ist jetzt die dritte Saison, in der sie sehr ordentlich, bis in dem Fall sogar perfekt, starten. Ich glaube, dieses Märchen ist ebenfalls vorbei, dass die zu packen sind. Ja, hat sich was verändert. Also Haaland, so fair muss man schon sein. Nach einem Sommer, in dem ja alle bei der EM oder bei der Copa waren, hatte der frei. Und in der Vorsaison hatte er vor allen Dingen zu kämpfen mit so einer elendlangen Fußverletzung. Und die scheint auch weg zu sein. Und das merkt man. Und zum anderen– und das ist das Erstaunliche an Pep Guardiola– immer, wenn der Rest es geschafft hat, seine offensiven Muster zu kopieren, dann kommt er einfach mit was Neuem. Und so macht das gerade. Das ist jetzt nicht gänzlich neu, aber der spielt halt wirklich nonstop mit 3-1-6 vorne und hat den Rechtsverteidiger Rico Lewis jetzt einfach nicht zum eingerückten Sechser gemacht, sondern zum eingerückten Zehner.
Also der Oskar Menges von City quasi.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er… Ja, ja, ja. Ja, ja, doch. Ich glaube, das wird Rico Lewis gerne über sich lesen. Das würde er sehr, sehr gerne über sich lesen. Wo würde er dann hingehen, von Manchester City zu? Das wäre dann das Zeltavigo der Premier League.
Tottenham, weiß ich nicht.
Setzt irgendjemand da auf Junge aus der eigenen Akademie und hat damit noch Erfolg und ist noch irgendein Alter da?
Auf Junge Spanier, die Wanderers, früher zumindest.
Ja, das stimmt. Wanderers auch eventuell.
Aber ich wollte gar nicht deinen Fluss so unterbrechen.
Ich würde mal drauf rum überlegen.
Also ein 3-1-6 mit eben sehr vielen Offensiven vorne drin.
Genau. Und vor allen Dingen in der Mitte. Es ist erstaunlich, wie intelligent einzelne Spieler sind. Er überrascht mich immer noch nach all den Jahren, die Bernardo Silvers, die Gündoans und wie sie alle heißen und wie sie es schaffen, trotzdem quasi gegen jedes Pressing ganz simpel rauszukommen. Selbst jetzt am Wochenende gegen Branford mal schwierige 20 Minuten gehabt, Gegentor nach 23 Sekunden sogar kassiert, aber kein Problem. Dann machen sie es halt hinterher und dann kommt sogar mal wieder eine Torhüterleistung zustande, die ich lange nicht mehr gesehen habe. Also City ist legit. Das ist so. Und das Problem bei Arsenal ist im Moment, die treffen wir jetzt schon aufeinander am Wochenende. Leider möchte ich fast sagen, weil Ödegarder gerade fehlt und Declan Rice ebenso. Das ist natürlich ein denkbar ungünstiger Zeitpunkt. Jetzt macht das Ateta zwar sehr, sehr clever, so ähnlich, wie ich mir das schon gedacht habe, hat das alles so weit gelöst, hat wieder ein eher defensiveres System, das sehr, sehr stark aufs Pressing ausgelegt ist, implementiert. Das hat jetzt auch am Wochenende gegen Tottenham schon mal ganz gut funktioniert. Ich glaube nur nicht, dass es gegen Manchester City funktioniert. Und dann gibt es auch die dritten im Bunde. Also nicht New Grasl, die habe ich jetzt trotz der guten Punktzahl nicht mit dabei, ganz oben, weil die Leistungen nicht den Ergebnissen entsprechen, sondern Liverpool. Auch wenn es da jetzt gegen Nottingham nicht gut ging mit Arne Slot zum ersten Mal, finde ich eigentlich, dass das im Wesentlichen einfach Jürgen Klopp plus ist, in Anführungszeichen. Also die Elemente, die sie hatten, die sie sehr gut gemacht haben, dieses extreme Umschalten, aber angereichert durch etwas mehr Spielkontrolle, einen etwas gemächlicheren Aufbau und dadurch weniger Tempo im Spiel, weniger Vertikalität. Das war ja mal mein Vorwurf an Liverpool, dass sie vielleicht etwas zu schnell umschalten und dann komplett die Linie verlieren, wenn es dann ein, zwei Mal hin und her geht. Und jetzt sind sie dadurch deutlich besser gestaffelt und ich muss gestehen. Ich freue mich sehr, dass Oranje Football da ist, die ich sehr, sehr schätze. Deswegen wollte ich eigentlich den Anzang hier noch schnell Ryan Grafenberg nennen. Ich baue den jetzt aber schnell damit ein. Vielleicht ist Ryan Grafenberg die Lösung aller Probleme für Liverpool auf der 6. Position. Das ist der Wahnsinn, wie der gerade loslegt. Ich habe das nie, nie, nie für möglich gehalten, dass der so stark einen Einzelsechser geben kann, wie er es gerade tut. Der spielt echt Wahnsinn im Moment.
Das haben wir auch gesehen in der Arsenalmannschaft, dass dann auch irgendwelche Pässe mit so einer Übersicht und Präzision angekommen sind, was wir vor einer Zeit auch nicht gedacht haben, dass das aus diesem Fußball rauskommt. Das muss man wirklich sagen, dass es auch nicht nur im Verein ist und das Lott, sondern jetzt auch in der Arsenalmannschaft der Fall war bei Ryan Grafenberg. Da sieht man, wie viel Potenzial auch wirklich in ihm steckt, wenn er noch mal aufblüht. Und er kann nach wirklich viel Liverpool wichtig werden.
Aber kann er eine 6 holen? Das ist das Einzige, was mich interessiert. Weil dann wäre doch einer für den Bayern.
Da könnte man mal drüber nachdenken, wenn man den holt und dann auf der Bank schmoren lässt.
Nicht schlecht, solchen Spielern auch mal Vertrauen zu schenken. Vielleicht, ja.
Ja, das ist Vertrauen übergewertet.
Aber fairerweise muss man echt sagen, das lag nicht nur an den Bayern in dem Fall. Der war wohl sehr ungeduldig.
Aber jetzt haben wir quasi das auf der einen Seite, eben das Sportliche bei Manchester City. Das ist auf jeden Fall zu loben. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich mir zum Beispiel einfach nur die Transfers angucke, Uli, dann sehe ich in der Vorsaison noch Ausgaben, netto Ausgaben von über 130 Millionen Euro. In dieser Saison sehe ich ein Transfer plus von fast 120 Millionen Euro so grob. Hat das etwa mit diesen 115 Anklagepunkten zu tun?
Ich möchte sagen ja, denn der untersuchte Zeitraum ist ja eigentlich schon abgeschlossen. Trotzdem haben wir gelernt, also glauben wir gelernt zu haben, leider Gottes ist er nach wie vor der große, große Kritikpunkt an der ganzen Sache. Die Premier League ist hinsichtlich der Strafen und der zustande gekommenen Urteile nicht transparent. Ich meine aber abzulesen an den zwei Fällen. Das ist natürlich jetzt auch, merke schon, das ist dämlich, was ich sage. Aber ich meine abzulesen an den zwei Fällen, dass die Premier League sowas wie wir probieren Besserung ganz leicht honoriert. Bei Nottingham weiß man es ja auch sogar, dass die noch versucht haben, ist auch eine total witzige Geschichte, der Zeitraum ist abgelaufen. Sie haben noch versucht, Brandon Johnson loszuwerden. Der hat so einen ganz witzigen juristischen Term Spieler 1a oder irgendwie so, glaube ich, nennen sie den in den Akten. Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass es Brandon Johnson ist. Man hat noch versucht, den Spieler zu verkaufen, um einfach den Verlust etwas zu mindern und hat das aber dann aufgrund des Beraterwechsels und dann des anderen Klubs nicht geschafft. Aber man hätte es ja gemacht, deshalb hat man dann Minus Minus 1 gegeben, aus Sicht der Premier League. Das heißt, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass City A schon für jetzt zeigen möchte, wir haben es verstanden und B schon für den nächsten Zeitraum denkt. Denn gerade hat die ganze Premier League echt Angst, weil niemand gedacht hat, dass die das Soriros durchziehen und dass die wirklich auch blutige Nasen verteilen, mit zum Teil schon echt gewaltigen Punktabzügen. Damit hat ja niemand gerechnet, dass sowohl Everton als auch Nottingham nicht beim allerersten Mal davon kommen mit einem Na ja, dann seid halt vorsichtig beim nächsten Mal, sondern bei Everton ist ja noch nicht mal gesagt, ob die nicht nochmal einkriegen für denselben Zeitraum. Und bei Nottingham sollte durch sein, aber keiner weiß es so richtig. Und deswegen kann ich mir schon auch vorstellen, dass City sagt, ja Moment, dann schauen wir lieber mal.
Ja, ansonsten hätten die Joao Cancelo nicht abgegeben, glaube ich. Das hat bestimmt eine wichtige Rolle in der Planung von Pep Guardiola gespielt.
Bist du halt gut aufgelegt, ne?
Es hat mir einfach so gefehlt, es hat mir so gefehlt, euch zuzuhören und mir die ganze Zeit zu überlegen, ist das jetzt eher wie Hoffenheim oder ist das wie Wolfsburg? Welchen Bundesliga-Vergleich kann ich da machen? Aber gibt es eine Zeit, eine Timeline, wann das jetzt dann zu einer Entscheidung kommen wird?
Ja, leider viel zu spät. Das ist ja auch immer der Kritikpunkt der Großes Nummer 2. Alle rechnen im März mit einem ersten Urteil, das dann ja wieder einmal kurz nichts hingenommen wird von Manchester City und dann kann es halt sein, dass das vor den Meisterschaftsrennen reingeht, was dann zusätzlichen Spannungsbogen schafft. Aber ich finde, das ist einfach doof. Man muss fairerweise dazu sagen, finde ich auch, weil das lese ich jetzt überall schon, dass alle sagen, hoffentlich macht die Premier League den Prozess richtig, damit City endlich verknackt wird. So ist es nicht. Das sind erst mal nur 115. Es gibt einen Journalisten, der tatkräftig mitgeholfen hat, beim rausbringen dieser Punkte. Der sagt, das sind sogar mehr. Das hat die Premier League nur falsch kommuniziert. Aber in all diesen Punkten ist nicht klar, dass ein Verstoß vorliegt. Sondern das ist offen, dieses Rennen. Und ich will auch gar nicht hergehen und sagen, ich hoffe. Sondern ich möchte gerne, also ich würde es gerne auch dann wissen, transparent, was sind denn die Punkte und wie sind sie jeweils bewertet worden. Also sprich, wie ging es aus, damit ich was ableiten kann auch für die zukunft. Weil ich habe das Gefühl, damit werde ich mich noch öfter rumschlagen jetzt in den nächsten paar Jahren. Aber es ist nicht so, dass da schon eine Vorverurteilung da sein sollte, sondern stopp. Jetzt guck mal erst mal.
Jetzt wird 115 Mal gestritten, deswegen dauert es ja auch bis März.
Genau, ganz genau. Deswegen dauert es. Und City ist ja nicht kooperativ. Das ist ja auch ein großer Unterschied zum Beispiel zu Nottingham Forest und den Teilen auch zu Everton, die manche Bilanzen aufgelegt haben. Forest ja komplett vollumfänglich, weil die eh schon wussten, dass nichts zu holen ist. Dafür haben sie ja auch nochmal Minus-Minus-Einen bekommen. City tut das nicht und behauptet, wir haben nichts verkehrt gemacht. Und das ist potentiell möglich, dass das so ist. Kann natürlich einfach auch nur eine Prozessstrategie sein. Das weiß ich nicht. Aber was mich ärgert, auch in seriösen Medien, dass so getan wird, als, ja gut, jetzt müssen sie nur den Prozess führen, damit wir endlich mal dieses Exempel statuieren. So ist es nicht. Also so nehme ich nicht wahr und so möchte ich es aber auch nicht haben.
Uli, ich kann dir nur aus italienischer Erfahrung schon mal viel Spaß damit wünschen. Bei Juve ist das jetzt ungefähr zwei Jahre her und da fiel das Urteil auch in der Zeit. Und ich kann dir schon mal viel Spaß damit wünschen, was alle anderen dann in der Liga dazu zu sagen haben. Denn da, wie du ja sagst, da müssen wir nicht drumherum reden, dass solche Entscheidungen massiven Einfluss auf die, ja, auf eine Tabelle, auf eine Endkonstellation, wie auch immer, haben werden. Ja, das ist nicht schön aus sportlicher Sicht.
Ja, das stimmt. Da bin ich auch schon echt gespannt drauf. Und ich meine, die Pressekonferenzen werden auch unerträglich in dieser Zeit. Da es einfach immer noch mehr um ein total gesetztes Thema geht, zu dem Guardiola ausnahmsweise mal nicht sagen wird.
Ja, auf der anderen Seite ist es aber durchaus interessant, dass wir fast so Verteidigungskämpfe sehen, in La Liga ja auch. Ich denke, wir müssen da jetzt nicht mehr ins Detail reingehen, aber es ist interessant, dass sich verschiedene Ligen jetzt schon Nachhaltigkeitsregeln gegeben haben, die den Turbokapitalismus auch nur ein bisschen einbremsen. Wirklich nur ein ganz kleines bisschen. Aber dass man eben auch bereit ist, das eben durchzuziehen. Und dass da große Namen– Barca, Baila Liga, jedes Jahr aufs Neue oder Sevilla– werden wir ja noch drüber sprechen. Sicherlich, dass die da auch von betroffen sind. Und das ist ja schon interessant. Ich frage mich, was da passiert ist. Also außer Corona. Corona war ein wichtiger Faktor. Aber woran das sonst liegt, dass die Liga-Verbände, die Gemeinschaft der Vereine glaubt, das tun zu müssen. Und ich bin gespannt, wann wir das auch noch in anderen Ligen sehen. Also vielleicht kann der Polizeigewerkschafter ja irgendwie nach seinem Job dann irgendwie so ein Tribunal anführen und dann wird immer Ajax angeklagt.
Uli, noch ein kleines Angebot in Sachen Haarland. Falls ihr Acerbi in der Premier League mehrere Wochen lang euch ausleihen möchtet, macht das. Denn der Herr hat Herrn Haarland jetzt ja schon zum zweiten Mal relativ gut im Griff.
Und hast du es gesehen? Der Haarland hat echt gebaggert am Trikot. Er wollte nicht loslassen. Er hat echt gesagt, komm, jetzt gib her. Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass Acerbi sagt, nee, komm. Das habe ich schon versprochen, aber dann war er hartnäckig.
Er ist echt auffällig, weil gestern im Champions League-Finale war es ja ähnlich. Da hat Acerbi echt auch einen guten Job gegen Haarland gemacht. Und gegen so eine Maschine, wie du gerade gesagt hast, die auch mit dem Selbstvertrauen daherkommt, dann das jetzt schon zum Wiederholten mal so zu spielen. Also das Matchup, sozusagen, liegt Acerbi ziemlich gut.
Allgemeine Blaupause. Also wenn wir schon mit dem Vergleichen sind, dann ist Inter so was wie Brentford.
Hat man glaube ich gestern auch.
Nicht andersherum wohlgemerkt, nicht andersherum.
Aber hat man bei Guardiola gestern ja auch wieder gehört, wer gemeint hat. Zwischen den Zeiten, die liegen uns halt nicht wirklich.
Es ist echt der Gegner mit der Art und Weise. Da haben sie gar keinen Bock drauf. Und so ähnlich hat es Brentford auch am Wochenende gemacht. Zumindest die ersten 20 Minuten. Mit etwas mehr Aggression ab Abstoß. Aber starkes Spiel von hinter.
Also 0 zu 0. Champions League am gestrigen Mittwoch. Für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das nicht mitbekommen haben. Damit sind wir schon einmal durch alle Ligen durchgeflogen. Und jetzt wollen wir unsere Awards verteilen. Das heißt MVP, Anzang Hero und Moment der letzten Woche. Oder Moment der Woche. Wir fassen das ein bisschen breiter. Das muss ich nicht auf den Spieltag beziehen. Und da gehen wir jetzt reihum durch. Daniel, du hast schon so lange nichts mehr sagen dürfen. Stell uns doch mal deinen MVP vor.
Also mein MVP ist von Arsene Alkmaar, Troy Parrott. Den muss man nicht zwingen kennen. Der ist doch relativ jung. Der ist erst 22. Hat aber schon die typische Laikarriere in der Family League durchlebt. Der kommt aus der Tottenham-Jugend und war dann bei Millwall, bei Ipswich-Town, bei dem Milton-Kate-Dons, bei Weston North End. Immer so eine halbe Saison, eine Saison gleich, dann wieder zurück.
Das klingt ehrlich gesagt wie das Loch von einem richtig geilen Groudhopper.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also gerade mit Millwall und Weston North End, also Millwall war ich sogar schon mal, Weston würde ich auch gerne hin. Das sind coole Vereine, aber die coolsten kamen dann später, nämlich die deräre Division, um ein bisschen Werbung zu machen. Er war dann 23, 24 bei Excelsior unter Rotterdam für eine Saison, hat da zehnmal genetzt und ist jetzt fest sogar bei Alkmaar und hat die ersten fünf Spiele gespielt von Beginn an, hat jetzt vier Tore erzielt beim 9 zu 1 von Alkmaar gegen Herntveen. Es war eine furchtbare Anliegenlage für Herntveen mit Robby van Persie als Trainer, der jetzt neu ist. Er ist jetzt neu als Trainer bei Herntveen und darf gleich mal in seiner ersten Saison ein 9 zu 1 rechtfertigen. Es gibt schönere Aufgaben als diese. Aber Troy Pabbott ist mit diesem Viererpack dann wirklich angekommen und zeigt auch noch mal so ein bisschen, was Aset Aikma so ein bisschen ausmacht, um mal vergleich zu ziehen. Es ist quasi so als Eintracht Frankfurt, der Eredivise, könnte man sagen.
Du passierst auch so gut rein, Daniel.
Ja, natürlich. Ich würde es wirklich mit Frankfurt vergleichen, die es immer schaffen, Aset Aikma Spieler zu holen, die so ein bisschen unterm Radar fliegen. Perot jetzt nicht ganz. Der hat ja jetzt schon vergangene Saison gezeigt, was der kann. Aber die holen die und verkaufen die dann ein, zwei Jahre später für das Dreifache. Also quasi so der huku Eki Tike oder Patscho zum Beispiel. Können sie auch. Sie haben jetzt versetzen müssen Paflides, der nach Manfica gegangen ist, der ja auch, glaube ich, bei einigen Bundesligisten im Gespräch war. Sogar bei Frankfurt, glaube ich sogar. Und der ist weg. Jetzt ist Perot da. Und der hat jetzt gleich mal einen Viererpack überschossen gegen Herrn Feyn und ist damit mein MVP des Spieltags jetzt.
Stark. Und man muss sagen, obwohl er schon so viele Leichtstationen hatte und die Liste ist wirklich lang, ist er 22 Jahre alt. Also das ist, wenn du halt immer von einer Halbserie verliehnst. Das ist, das ist, ja. Gut, wir werden es beobachten. Und spielt er zentral oder spielt er auf dem Flügel? Weil er kann beides laut seinem Profil hier.
Genau, also er wird zentral in der Regel eingesetzt. Das ist quasi wirklich der eins-zu-eins-Ersatz von Pavlidis. Weil er hat auch die Neuen und macht zumindest jetzt mal seinen Namen aller Ehre. Er brauchte ja ein bisschen. Die ersten vier Spiele waren torlos, was nicht heißt, dass er für das Spiel irrelevant war. Also er macht die Bälle auch gut fest und bewegt sich gut. Aber am Ende brauchst du halt Tore. Und die sind jetzt zumindest mal da seit letzter Woche.
Stark. Troy Parrott. Den Namen merken wir uns. Und dann gibt es ja noch einen völlig unbekannten, den wir in La Liga mal feiern müssen. Da haben sich bestimmt vorhin schon einige gesagt, was? Das ist nicht das wichtigste Thema aus La Liga? Das kann ja gar nicht sein. Fabian, wollen wir vielleicht doch ein bisschen über Hansi Flick sprechen?
Wir müssen über Hansi Flick sprechen. Es ist für mich auch die, naja, ich weiß nicht, ob es die große Überraschung ist, aber es ist definitiv überraschend, wie er mit diesem Chaos-Club im Moment, zumindest muss ich ihn so bezeichnen, FC Barcelona in die Saison gestartet ist, mit fünf Siegen aus fünf Spielen, mit 17 zu 4 Toren, mit einem wunderbaren Fußball, mit einem Mut, dem ich ihm auch zusprechen muss. Er hat jetzt die ersten Spiele mit zwei Spielern aus der zweiten Mannschaft im zentralen Mittelfeld agiert, auf der 6. oder 8. Position, bis Petri jetzt wieder fit geworden ist, die letzten zwei Spiele. Leider hat sich einer der beiden, also die beiden heißen Juan Bernal, und der andere heißt Marc Casado. Der Bernal hat sich leider vor nicht letzten Spiel, sondern vorletzten Spieltag einen Kreuzbandriss zugezogen und ist jetzt leider raus, war aber mit 17 Jahren einfach schon Taktgeber. Das erste Mal überhaupt, dass er für Barca gespielt hat. Marc Casado spielt nach wie vor, denn es ist unter anderem Janosch Gavi verletzt und Frenkie de Jong verletzt. Der macht es auch einfach richtig stark, hat einen Traumpass hingelegt beim Kantersieg von Barcelona jetzt am Wochenende in Chirona bei ihm. Einer der Erzfeine zumindest, zumindest lokales katalanisches Derby. Unglaublich. Also da muss ich dem Kollegen oder was heißt nicht dem Kollegen, aber da muss ich Hansi Flick echt ein großes Lob aussprechen und seinem Trainerteam, wie die das hinbekommen haben, auch in dieser schwierigen Sommerphase das Team zusammenzuhalten. Unbeirrt all dieser Transfergeschichten, diese Wirren dort relativ ruhig gearbeitet hat und was die im Moment da auf dem Platz hinzaubern ist wirklich wirklich sehenswert. Natürlich mit einem Lamin Jamal, der also ich weiß es nicht, aber Wer?
Ist der gut?
Nee, also er ist wirklich überragend, finde ich vor allen Dingen. Also Messi war in dem Alter auf jeden Fall nicht weit nicht zu spielen, scheiden wie Jamal ist. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, bei Messi standen ja noch viele Stars außen rum und die mussten wir vielleicht dann eher die Tore machen. Aber Lamin Jamal macht mit 17 Jahren den Unterschied, er entscheidet die Spiele. Was habe ich mir aufgeschrieben? Drei Tore, vier Assists in fünf Spielen. Unfassbar, unfassbar einfach. Barcelona ist komischerweise total ruhig, entspannt, sportlich. Alles andere ist natürlich noch im Verkauf. Ihr habt es ja mitbekommen im Sommer, die halbe zweite Mannschaft wurde verkauft, irgendwelche Spieler mussten noch wegnehmen, um irgendwie Dani Olmo zu finanzieren, der die ersten zwei Spiele nicht spielen durfte, weil er so gehalsmäßig noch nicht reingepasst hat. Also Katastrophe nach wie vor, die Führung von Präsident Laporta. Aber ich habe mich jetzt entschieden, Barcelona nicht als Hauptthema zu nehmen. Das soll dann mein Kollege Alex Druecker machen, der ist ja da noch ein bisschen mehr mit dem Herzen dabei. Aber wie gesagt, Hansi Flick, MVP, ohne Frage der Mann der Liga bisher.
Und da sieht man nämlich mal, wohin meine beißende Ironie und meine schlechten Witzchen immer führt. Ich habe es ihm nicht zugetraut, habe das hier deutlich kundgetan. Natürlich warten wir jetzt mal ab, wie es noch in 10, 15, 20 Spielen aussieht, aber dieser Start ist definitiv erwähnenswert gewesen und eben, also ich möchte es noch mal rausstellen, du hast es schon genannt, aber 5 Spiele, 17 zu 4 Tore. Das ist schon nicht so schlecht, muss man sagen. Hansi Flick oder wie du ihn genannt hast, Gansi Flick, das fand ich auch sehr schlimm. Ich überlege, dass er ein Showbox ist.
Copyright allerdings beim Kollegen Drücker. Also Gansi Flick kommt von ihm, aber ist nett.
Stark. Sehr, sehr schön. Das ist unser MVP aus der Liga. Christian, wen wollen wir in der Serie A hervorheben?
Wir gehen ins beschauliche Udiné. Denn Udiné ist sehr grüßvoll auf der Wellenspitze nach vier Spieltagen und nehmen uns den Herrn Florian Thauvin zu Herzen. Ja, genau, dafür holen wir jetzt kurz mal den Kopfschirm.
Du hast seine Debuts kommentiert, du hast mit seiner Mutter gesprochen.
So alt bin ich auch noch nicht.
Genau, also mal eine kurze Einordnung, Thauvin.
Ich weiß zu viel über ihn, ja, das stimmt.
Französischer Weltmeister von 2018, also war Teil des WM-Kaders, Marseille Newcastle, deshalb hier die Reaktion von Uli. Und dann ist er nach Mexiko gewechselt, für sehr, sehr viel Geld. Er hat einen wahnsinnig hochdotierten Vertrag unterschrieben, ist auf die Spuren von Gignac gegangen, der ja der andere Franzose, der in Mexiko da groß durchgestartet ist. Aber das hat nicht so funktioniert. Anscheinend wurden am Ende auch ein paar Gehaltszahlungen ausgeblieben. Lange Rede kurzer Sinn, im Winter, 23. Januar, 23. ist er zu Uli gekommen. Ja, und jetzt ist er– letzte Saison hat das so halb funktioniert, ich glaube, am Ende waren es fünf Tore. Und jetzt steht er– jetzt ist er neuer Kapitän der Mannschaft und steht nach vier Spieltagen mit drei Toren und einer Vorlage auf Platz 1 der Scorer. Am Wochenende lag Udinese 0 zu 2 in Parma zurück. Parma Überraschungsmannschaft hatte Milan schon geschlagen gegen Napoli, groß, gut mitgehalten. Und dann dritt Udinese, das Spiel noch gewinnt 3-2, Thauvin macht zwei Puden. Und genau, Udinese jetzt auf Platz 1, Thauvin auch die meisten erfolgreichen Dribblings der Liga bisher, also kleiner Wusliger, so hinter der Spitze. Die haben mit Lorenzo Lucca drin so einen massiven Neuner. Und Thauvin wuselt da vor sich hin, knipst jetzt auch, spürt die Verantwortung eben als Kapitän. Und neben Thauvin müssen wir jetzt logischerweise auch Kostil Roneajic kurz nennen, denn das ist eben der Trainer, der neue Trainer in Udinese, kam ja aus Polen. Und ja, macht da im Moment einen sehr, sehr, sehr soliden Job. Hat im Prinzip gar nicht viel geändert. Also dieses 3-5-2, 3-4-2-1, das Udinese jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile schon seit vielen Jahren spielt, hat da einfach durchgeführt, aber hat Ordnung reingebracht. Ein bisschen mehr kreative Momente eben für die, eben steht Thauvin. Und anderer Name vielleicht, der ein paar noch was sagt, Kahn Indler, ehemaliger Schweizer Nationalspieler, langjähriger Udinese Spieler, der jetzt auch technischer Direktor ist, der das zusammen mit Roneajic führt. Und ja, jetzt steht Udinese als alleiniger Tabellenführer, zum ersten Mal, Achtung, seit 13 Jahren, damals noch, jetzt mal schauen, wer die Herren noch kennen, Toto Di Natale, Antonio Di Natale, damals noch, bei Udinese im Tor, Samir Handanovic und in der Abwehr einer der großen Bayern-Legenden, Mehdi Benazir. Also, schöne Geschichte, dass das beschauliche Udinese, ja, so gut gestartet ist.
Zeigt leider aber auch, was so eine Tabellenführung nach vier Spieltagen aussagt.
Noch mal, deswegen habe ich es ja auch nicht zum großen Thema gemacht. Das sind vier Spiele. Das wird sich alles wieder einbändeln. Aber Udinese war letztes Jahr bis zum letzten Spieltag noch eine halbe Stunde vor Schluss warm, die vor dem Abstieg. Dementsprechend tut es jetzt logischerweise gut, auch wenn sich das alles wieder einordnen wird. Aber du hast jetzt einfach mal nach vier Spielen schon zehn Punkte und die könnten dir auf lange Frist dann sicherlich helfen und dir auch ein bisschen mehr Ruhe und Stabilität geben.
Ein Abstiegskandidat, der in der Nachfolgesaison an der Tabellenspitze mitmischt. Ist Costa Runeyec, der Sebastian Hoeneß, der Silvia Arndt.
Dazu sprechen wir uns ein paar Monate noch mal.
Werde einer für die Bayern.
Hat er einen Spitzennamen schon bekommen von der italienischen Sportpresse? Das würde mich interessieren.
Habe ich jetzt noch nicht mitbekommen. Vielleicht, weißt du, in Udinä ist das alles, da gehen die Uhren ein bisschen anders. Also das ist alles sehr, da ist nicht so gut. Der Medienrummel nicht so groß. Alles ruhig da. Also die machen sich jetzt auch da kein riesen Ding draus. Deswegen habe ich es jetzt eben auch in die Worts gepackt. Okay, aber der VfB vergleichlich ist zu denen zurück. Nee, nee, nee. Die wissen da, was sie tun. Und wie gesagt, die haben einfach schon mal zehn Punkte nach vier Spielen. Das wird ihnen den Job in den nächsten Monaten deutlich erleichtern.
Den Eindruck habe ich aber auch. So, und dann fehlt uns noch ein MVP aus der Premier League. Und nachdem Erling Haaland schon genannt wurde, bin ich jetzt wirklich gespannt, Uli.
Ich jubel dir immer ein Unter. Und das mache ich jetzt hier auch. Wenn es ein Überraschungsteam gibt in England, und obwohl es nicht überraschend ist auf der einen Seite, weil das Programm so leicht war, bis auf Liverpool, dann ist es Nottingham Forests, die gut performen. Und es gibt, glaube ich, nur einen, den man dann– nein, es gibt zwei, die man nennen könnte, Chris Wood, der einfach fleißig trifft die ganze Zeit. Aber vor allen Dingen Morgan Gibson White, der einfach die Offensive da ist. Also wenn der ein vernünftiges Spiel hat, dann ist Nottingham vernünftig. Und andersherum gesagt, wenn der ausfallen sollte, dann sind die weg vom Fenster. Dann traue ich denen gar nichts mehr zu. Und deswegen seien die genannt, weil auch Morgan Gibson White eine ganz interessante Biografie hat, wie die meisten, die wir jetzt hier genannt haben. Also relativ linear zwar, aber kam für rund 30 Millionen Euro als absoluter Ersatzspieler. Also der war nie mehr. Er hat, glaube ich, nicht einmal von Beginn an gespielt für die Wolves seinerzeit zu Nothing in Forest. Und dann haben wir damals gesagt, genau so krank ist das System in England nämlich. Und zwei Jahre später sieht das aus, als wäre es geschenkt für das, was der macht. Weil, debütiert für England, jetzt auch in der Länderspielpause, sah gut aus, hat so ein ganz freakyes Talent, weil der so schnell ist, so beweglich zur Seite. Und ich nenne solche Spieler immer All Action. Also so eine 8-10, das weiß ich noch gar nicht ganz genau, wo es dann idealerweise mal hingeht, aber auf alle Seiten, nach vorne, nach hinten, zur Seite, der ist überall und ist ein guter Verteidiger, ist super clever im Pressing und hat dann aber obendrauf auch nochmal dieses wahnsinnige Tempo für sämtliche Konter, die erfahren könnte, ist clever abseits des Balles und ist halt so unberechenbar. Und das ist das, was Nottingham Forest sonst so nicht hat, weil die sind ansonsten sehr, sehr berechenbar. Aber sie haben den Sieg geholt, den sie, wenn sie den holen, immer holen, gegen Liverpool, jetzt am Wochenende auch und haben einfach nur 0-1 gewonnen. Nachdem die erste Hälfte, haben sie es einfach mal ausgehalten. In der zweiten Hälfte macht er nun Espirito Santo. Also ich glaube, der hat einen sehr guten Analysten, weil ab zweiter Hälfte sieht es einfach immer besser aus bei denen. Und dann haben sie langsam angefangen, ihre ein, zwei Konterstrategien auszufahren und irgendwann war einer drin. Da war zwar jetzt Gibbs White nicht direkt beteiligt, aber er hat aus meiner Sicht trotzdem einen großen, großen Anteil an der ganzen Sache.
Den Namen merken wir uns. Den kann man sich ja auch ganz gut merken. Dann kommen wir zu den Anstang Heroes. Daniel, wen hast du uns da mitgebracht?
Ich habe von Twente Insrede Sam Stein mitgebracht. Der ist ein bisschen– also bei uns in der Liga ist er eigentlich kein Anstang Hero, ein durchschossener Hero. Aber für unsere Wahrnehmung ist er außerhalb der Liga, der hat immer so ein bisschen leicht unterm Radar. Der ist Mittelfeldspieler bei Twente, Offensiver, ist auch erst 22 und macht dafür auch schon wieder herausragend. Der hat jetzt in der Saison in fünf Spielen schon vier Tore wieder erzielt und ist so eine Art Lebensversicherung von Twente. Wir haben uns immer gedacht, dass es eigentlich jetzt schon im Transferfenster die Zeit gekommen wäre, dass er ins europäische Ausland wechselt, in einer der Top-5-Ligen. Es gab mal Gerüchte über Werder. Das hätte mich persönlich auch gefreut, wenn der zu Werder gekommen wäre. Daraus wurde aber nichts. Wie heißt das wirklich wahr? Das ist dann auch die Frage. Es gibt hier und da blocken Gerüchte auf, aber letztendlich vergeblieben. Er macht die Sache bei Twente sehr, sehr gut und ist eigentlich einer der Bausteine bei Twente im Mittelfeld. Er dirigiert, er hat eine hohe Ballsicherheit, kann den kreativen Fass finden. Das ist so ein bisschen das, was uns so umtreibt eigentlich schon seit Länge, warum er eigentlich immer noch bei Twente ist. Klingt irgendwie ein bisschen fies, aber ist so das, was wir uns so fragen letztendlich.
Ja, liegt es vielleicht ein bisschen an der Spielweise von Twente? Also wenn man jetzt nicht Highlights von denen suchen würde, wären das ja eher die 1.30er-Zusammenfassungen, oder?
Ja, also Twente ist jetzt nicht so bekannt, dass die Alkma imitieren mit den 1.30er. Sie sind eigentlich eher schon auf Sicherheit aus, auf Defensive. Das stimmt schon, das könnte vielleicht deshalb auch sein. Und ich glaube auch, dass wenn Sam Stein in einem Team ist, was offensiver ausgerichtet wäre, der quasi noch präsenter und noch stärker am Rampenlicht stehen würde. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, gerade wenn Sam Stein auch vielleicht innerhalb der Liga wechseln würde, zu einem Team, was mehr presst. Wenn ich jetzt an Eindhoven denke zum Beispiel, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass er noch prominenter gerückt wird. Aber so ein bisschen ist er– vielleicht tut Sven Teh ihm nicht gut, aber das wäre auch ein bisschen fies formuliert tatsächlich. Aber ich glaube, dass es ein Spieler ist, den man auf jeden Fall in zukunft auf dem Radar haben muss, der auch irgendwann seinen Weg in eine der 5 Ligen gehen wird. Davon gehe ich fest aus.
Den behalten wir im Auge. Uli hat sich alles schon notiert, um dann sein Premier League-Debüt kommentieren zu können. Dann brauchen wir noch einen Anzang Hero aus der Serie A, bitte. Christian?
Ja, da landen wir bei Davis Vazquez. Jetzt bin ich gespannt, ob Uli auch nickt. Noch nicht. Ich sehe keine Nektion. 26-jähriger kolumbianischer Torhüter, den hat Milan vor eineinhalb Jahren geholt und seitdem nur ausgeliehen. Unter anderem zu Sheffield. Der hat eine Rückrunde für Sheffield gespielt, auch ein paar Spiele gemacht. Er war dann letzte Saison an Ascoli ausgeliehen, in Serie B, und wurde jetzt diese Saison an Empoli ausgeliehen. Und Vazquez steht stellvertretend für Empoli. Denn Empoli gebe ich auch zu, für mich auch vor der Saison, einer der Abstiegskandidaten. Steht nach vier Spielen noch ungeschlagen da, sechs Punkte und hat unter anderem gegen Juve, Roma und Bologna– ist eines Zeichen Champions League Teilnehmer– gespielt. Hat in Rom gewonnen, 2-1 bei der Roma, da die Roma eben ins Loch gestürzt. Jetzt am vergangenen Wochenende 0-0 gegen Juve zuhause. Echt gut mitgehalten. Am Ende sogar noch ein, zwei Chancen auf den Sieg gehabt. Und der Herr Vazquez eben, der Kolumbianer im Tor, hat wirklich sowohl in Rom als jetzt auch gegen Juve ganz, ganz stark gehalten. Haben jetzt in vier Spielen zwei Gegentore kassiert als einer der potenziellen Abstiegskandidaten. Und dementsprechend ja sinnbildlich einer, der jetzt nicht groß auf der Liste steht, den eben die wenigsten wahrscheinlich auch kennen. Aber eben der mit Empoli wirklich, ja, das bisher sehr gut macht. Und anders als Boudinese, würde ich eben sagen, zählen dann die sechs Punkte ein bisschen mehr, wenn man sich halt eben die Gegner anschaut. Denn in Rom gegen Juve und auch, wenn Bologna jetzt sicherlich auch noch mit Problemen gestartet ist, aber es ist halt trotzdem Champions League-Teilnehmer. Und wenn du da aus Empolis Sicht ungeschlagen rausgehst, sogar sechs Punkte mitnimmst, dann ist das logisch ein großartiger Start und Vasquez hat da großen Anteil daran.
Es ist noch sehr, sehr früh, das weiß ich. Aber kann es sein, dass sich wirklich interessanter Abstiegskampf in der Serie A ankündigen?
Wahnsinnig, absolut. Also ich habe es schon, ich dachte es mir schon vor dem Start und jetzt hat sich es komplett rauskristallisiert. Also für mich ist eine Mannschaft, also wenn sich die dieses Jahr rettet, dann ist das für mich eines der größten sportlichen Geschichten der letzten Jahre. Das ist Venedig. Also bei Venedig kann ich mir im Moment nicht vorstellen, wie die sich retten sollen. Aber nach Venedig könnte ich die jetzt 5, 6 nennen, die da definitiv reinrutschen können. Empoli wird da auch immer, wird da im Spiel bleiben, auch trotz dieses Starts. Aber bin ich völlig bei dir, Max? Also der Abstiegskampf in Italien ist ja wahnsinnig schwer zu prognostizieren. Ich habe auch Monza ein bisschen auf der Rechnung. Jetzt spielen die plötzlich 1-1 gegen Inter am Wochenende und gewinnen fast. Klar, das ist alles Saisonstart, ist schon klar. Aber ich glaube, der Abstiegskampf in der Serie A wird wahnsinnig eng, wahnsinnig heiß und vielleicht der Klassiker ist immer das noch ein, zwei reinrutschen, mit denen man nicht gerechnet hat. Also, ja, da glaube ich wirklich, bis auf Venedig werden sich da sehr, sehr viele warm anziehen müssen. Oder umgekehrt, können viele vielleicht positiv überraschen.
7 von 20 Teams haben noch keinen Sieg nach vier Spieltagen. Das habe ich so auch noch nicht häufig gesehen in einer Tabelle. Wir gucken es uns genau an und wir gucken natürlich auch auf den Ansagen. Hier der La Liga. Das war jetzt falsch, also der spanischen Liga. Fabian, wen hast du uns mitgebracht?
Ich habe euch wieder einen Trainer mitgebracht und ihr werdet euch jetzt ein bisschen wundern, denn er steht im Moment am Tabellenende der Primärdivision. Es ist Valencias Trainer Ruben Maraja und er ist, glaube ich, so die ärmste Sau auf dem spanischen Trainermarkt oder in der spanischen Trainerwelt im Moment. Valencia zu trainieren macht spätestens seit Peter Lim dem Verein gehört überhaupt keinen Spaß und seit zwei Jahren noch viel weniger, auch katastrophal geführt. Die besten Spieler werden jedes Jahr verkauft. Es werden Spieler hingestellt, die der Trainer nicht möchte und Ruben Maraja hat letztes Jahr aus der Not eine Thun gemacht, hat viele junge Spieler hochgezogen, zwangsweise, weil ihm einfach Spielmaterial gefehlt hat und hat die letztes Jahr zu einem wirklich, muss ich sagen, sehr competitive, wettbewerbsfähigen Team gemacht, die letztes Jahr vielleicht sogar überperformt haben und ich glaube sogar einen einstelligen Tabellenplatz am Ende hatten. Und ich habe mir das erste Saisonspiel angesehen, Valencia FC Barcelona, auch um das Debüt von Flick zu sehen und so weiter. Und Valencia ist da in Führung gegangen mit 1 zu 1, hat wirklich, wirklich stark gespielt. Man hat halt irgendwann gemerkt, ok, es fehlt die individuelle Klasse und Barcelona hat das dann noch gedreht mit 2 zu 1. Aber das war so ein Knackpunkt für beide Trainer, so ein bisschen für Flick war das so der gelungene Auftakt für die Spieler, das Zeichen-Case passt. Bei Valencia ging es ein bisschen nach hinten los. Die haben dann die nächsten Spiele alle unglücklich verloren, würde ich sagen, bis auf das letzte Spiel, das war bei Atletico mit 3-0, da war wenig zu holen. Jetzt haben sie natürlich auch noch interne Probleme zu meistern. Hugo Duro, ihr bester Stürmer, ist verletzt. Rafa Mir, den anderen Stürmer, dem sie haben, dem wird im Moment sexuelle Aggression vorgeworfen. Er ist zwar freigesprochen, aber die Vereinsführung, die gute Vereinsführung und nette Vereinsführung, hat dem Trainer auch bemittelt, hey, der ist freigesprochen, den kannst du wieder haben. Ruben Barach hat aber gesagt, nee, ich will, dass der jetzt erst mal mindestens zwei Spiele noch pausiert. Das ist eine Disziplinlosigkeit, ganz egal, ob der Vorwurf stimmt oder nicht. Es ist im Nachtleben passiert, er hat sich nicht professionell verhalten. Das wird jetzt erst mal von mir bestraft, auch als Signal wahrscheinlich an die Mannschaft. Das macht er wirklich in keiner einfachen Lage, denn er hat im Kader keine Alternativen auf der Stürmerposition, also wenige, die ihn weiterbringen würden. Vor allen Dingen, weil er es letztes Jahr so überragend gemacht hat und weil er dieses Jahr auch wieder sich da wirklich mannhaft– mannhaft klingt bescheuert– weil er sich vor sein Team stellt und das Beste rausholt, wünsche ich ihm ganz viel Erfolg, auch für dieses Jahr wieder. Denn ich glaube, es ist fast der schwerste Platz, wo man im Moment im Spanien trainieren kann, auch wenn es ein Traditionsverein ist und auch wenn viele Möglichkeiten eigentlich da wären. Aber es ist alles andere als leichter zu arbeiten. Und er macht das bisher, finde ich, sehr, sehr gut. Und deswegen ist er für mich mein Ansatz-Hero.
Also der Downfall von Valencia beginnend mit dem Champions-League-Final-Teilnamen Anfang der 2000er um die Jahrtausendwende bis jetzt. Ach, das wäre mal so ein schönes achtstündiges Tribüngespräch. Aber mal gucken.
Wenn das neue Stadion kommt, wird alles besser.
Ja, das ist ja wie, wenn endlich der letzte Band von das Lied von Eis und Feuer rauskommt, dann ist das Ende der Lebensstoffe nicht mehr so schlecht. Aber gut. Das ist Valencia und Ruben Barraja. Sehr schön, dass du ihn hier mit reingebracht hast. Uli, du hast vorhin reingegraben, du hast schon genannt, das war dein Anzeigenhero, den du besprechen wolltest.
Nein, den habe ich, den habe ich.
Hast mir noch jemand untergejubelt.
Ja, ich würde dir noch schnell einen unterjubeln, weil dann ist auch der mit drin. Auch das mache ich durch die Hintertür, weil sein Trainer wird des Öfteren besungen, ist Manager of the Month geworden im August. Finde ich zu Recht übrigens, ich nenne mal Tony Bloom, Besitzer von Brighton, weil ganz oft wird gesagt, Besitzer und Investoren sind nur Müll. Die Chelsea-Story, dass die sich schon wieder trennen wollen und einfach nur Geld rausprüfern und so weiter. Als Beispiel auch nicht ganz korrekt, aber es gibt auch die Gegenbeispiele und Tony Bloom ist so eins, der sehr datenorientiert den Verein führt, aber sich auch wahnsinnig viel sagen lässt und ein Transferfenster hingelegt hat, das für mich der Wahnsinn ist. Daniel wird 90 Prozent derer kennen, die gekommen sind oder Leistungsträger sind gerade, also Verbrücken, Van Hecke, Feldmann. Dann haben sie Minttee geholt, ebenfalls aus Niederlanden, Mats Viver natürlich vor allen Dingen. Das ist, glaube ich, sogar der Königstransfer, auch wenn der nur einmal gespielt hat bis jetzt. Brian Guder haben sie verpflichtet, nicht Niederlande, aber in der Nähe zumindest.
Stimmt, das wäre ein Niederländer.
Stimmt, das wäre ein Niederländer auch, genau. Und den Zerbi-Abgang und die Abgänge der größeren Spieler der letzten Jahre, wie immer schon ein bis zwei Jahre vorher abgefangen und auch ansonsten, glaube ich, ein sehr guter Typ und auch einer, den man sich wahrscheinlich als Fan dieser Truppe wünscht, weil der selber nämlich schon immer Fan war von Brighton, gerne selber Profi geworden wäre. Dann hat er sich entschieden, dass er Profi-Spieler wird. Muss jeder selber wissen. Aber hat diese Gambler-Ader nicht in den Verein mitgebracht, sondern im Gegenteil, führt ihn sehr vorausschauend und hat mit Fabian Hützler, glaube ich, auch jemanden geholt, der wunderbar passt und mit dem sie die zukunft haben dürften. Das sieht bis dato echt sehr gut aus, muss ich sagen. Gestern war es wohl nicht so gut. EFL Cup habe ich nur gelesen, aber habe nichts gesehen. Da war Hützler wohl auch nicht so ganz glücklich. Aber bis dahin ist es ansonsten eine gute Saison.
Ja, da werden wir, glaube ich, immer mal wieder drauf schauen auf Brighton. Das ist ja wirklich eine erstaunliche Geschichte. Dann haben wir noch den Moment der Woche oder der letzten Wochen. Daniel, was ist da aus den Niederlanden zu berichten?
Ja, ich konnte mich entscheiden. Ich habe zwei Momente genommen.
Hast du mir etwas untergegeben? Von wem hast du dir das denn abgedeckt?
Ja, ich kann aber dem einen Untergegebenen auch direkt anschließen an Oli, denn es geht auch um Feyernoord, also der Verein, von dem er als FIFA gekommen ist für 32 Millionen. Denn die Bremmer League hat zum Besten dafür auch gesorgt, dass Feyernoord jetzt ziemlich schlecht da steht. Annes Lotz, Liverpool, Merckmann Riesig, dem neuen Trainer, den Bliske, der erst versucht hat, ein neues System zu implementieren. In 3-5-2 ist dann nach 1-2 Spieltagen schon wieder umgeschwenkt auf dem 4-3-3, weil es nicht funktioniert hat, aufgrund auch der fehlenden Wingwigs mit Luffes und Bart Newcob, die dafür nicht geeignet sind für so ein vielen Systeme in der Dreierkette. Und Feyernoord ist aktuell auf Platz 8 mit 6 Punkten aus 4 Spielen. Das ist nicht der Anspruch von Feyernoord, die auch durch Abgänge, auch Herdreuder, so Leipzig zum Beispiel, relativ spät auch im Transferfenster, jetzt vor kurzem erst Probleme hatten und haben da gleichwertig gute Leute dann auch nachzuholen tatsächlich. Und in meinem Moment sind die Momente nach den Spielen, wo es zu einem Huddle kommt. Also im Prinzip so ein Kreis von den Spielern, der bei uns normal ist. Nach dem Spiel hebt man in der Mannschaft zusammen, bespricht sich noch mal kurz, pusht sich. Und das ist in den Niederlanden nicht so üblich, zumindest nicht so regelmäßig. Und der neue Trainer, der neue Trainer Brian Priske, hat es selber etabliert, nach jedem Spiel. Und dann gibt es jetzt in der Presse, in den Niederlanden, die wildesten Diskurse und Debatten über diese Huddles, diese Mannschaftskreise. Da werden dann Psychologen zur Art gezogen, die ja nur überurteilen, ja, es ist ja eigentlich wichtig, dass man diesen Moment, deswegen habe ich es auch jetzt als Moment gewählt, den Moment nach der Nierlage oder nach dem Spiel der Mannschaft bespricht. Und nicht erst mit den Fans oder mit der Familie oder einzelnen Kollegen. Und dann gibt es dann wieder viele Tweets, die dich darüber auslasten und lustig machen. Also es gibt dann viele Debatten, auch noch absatzsportliche, über sowas zum Beispiel, die dem Trainer Priske dann auch nicht schmecken dürfen tatsächlich. Das fand ich dann auch irgendwie im passenden Moment, über den Moment nach dem Spielern zu reden.
Ja, sehr gut. Ganz kurzer Hinweis. Grüße gehen raus an Jason von den Wochenend-Rebellen. Der würde sich sehr darüber freuen, wenn mal auf den Mannschaftskreis verzichtet wird. Aber das wissen jetzt nur alle, die Wochenend-Rebellen hören oder den Film gesehen haben oder das Buch gelesen haben, die Bücher gelesen haben. So, und dann dein zweiter Moment.
Der fließt sich auch an Feyernoord an. Das ist ein langer ruter Faden, den ich jetzt hier ziehe. Denn der zweite Moment gehört Kroningen. Die sind Aufsteiger. Die sind zuletzt vor zwei Jahren dann abgestiegen unter sehr viel Lärm mit vielen Protesten der Fans, die das Stadion dann den Innenraum gestürmt haben. Es gab Spielabbrüche nach Becherwürfen und so weiter und so fort. Die sind jetzt aber da aufgestiegen direkt und haben jetzt nach fünf Spieltagen neun Punkte. Sie sind auf Platz vier und haben noch nicht verloren. Sie haben gegen Alkmaar auch in Rémy errungen und jetzt auch gegen Feyernoord. Nach 2-0 Rückstand haben sie dann in der 90. Bus 1 noch das 2-2 erzielen können. Das ganze Stadion ist im hohen Norden, der die ganze Ektase pur eskaliert. Das ist ein dauernder Moment von Roningen, die defensiv sehr gut stehen und darüber auch viele Punkte mitnehmen. Dieser Moment ist jetzt kulminiert bei diesem Ausgleichs-Tor gegen Feyernoord. Ich glaube, das haben sich auch die Vereine nach den letzten Jahren verdient.
Da werden wir, glaube ich, auch immer mal wieder noch mal draufschauen. Schöne zwei Momente. Fabian, was möchtest du uns aus La Liga noch berichten?
Ja, ich habe mich für das Tor von Jesus Navas entschieden für den FC Sevilla, der einen 1-0-Sieg für diesen Club gesichert hat. Das war der erste Saisonsieg. Sevilla ist auch alles andere als gut in die Saison gestartet und hat extreme finanzielle Probleme. Sie haben eigentlich nur ein insgesamtes Transferbudget von 2,5 Millionen Euro für das ganze Team für die ganze Saison. Transfer-
oder Gehaltbudget?
Gehaltbudget, genau. Jetzt ist es natürlich so, dass der Liga-Präsident Tewas Sevilla ein bisschen hilft und die jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen mauscheln lässt und so weiter. Man will ja nicht einen Traditionsclub gleich total abschießen und so weiter und so fort. Aber dementsprechend könnt ihr euch vorstellen, dass auch was kadermäßig Verstärkungen anbelangt, wenig passiert ist und viel verkauft worden ist. Jetzt ist es so, dass Jesus Navas eigentlich Sevilla-Legende, ehemaliger Nationalspieler, war auch bei der EM dabei, glaube ich sogar noch, dass er eigentlich gar keinen Vertrag mehr hatte beim FC Sevilla. Und die Fans dann so laut stark protestiert haben und der Spieler auch selbst gesagt hat, er hätte sich gewünscht, irgendwie schön von seinem Verein verabschiedet zu werden. Das hat eben nicht geklappt letztes Jahr und dann hat aber der Präsident dann doch noch eingelenkt und hat ihm noch mal ein Jährchen gegeben. Ja und jetzt hat er den ersten Saisonsieg erzielt und ist danach in Tränen ausgebrochen und hat danach im Interview gesagt, er ist jetzt glaube ich auch schon 7 oder 38, dass er eigentlich nur jeden zweiten Tag gehen kann im Moment. Also er trainiert einen Tag, muss einen Tag Pause machen, weil er nicht mehr kann, dann trainiert er wieder einen Tag, dann muss er wieder pausieren und er ist nach wie vor für Sevilla unwahrscheinlich wichtig und hat jetzt wie gesagt den ersten Saison-Sieg für die erzählt und ist dementsprechend ja auch sehr emotional dann eben berührt gewesen und war für mich dann– es gab mehrere Geschichten, aber das war auf jeden Fall der Moment des letzten Wochenendes.
Und bei Sevilla, also sie werden diese zweieinhalb Millionen Gehaltsbudget, wenn sie sich einhalten können, da wird es noch Punktabzüge, sonst was geben, also das wird noch ein Thema dieses Saison werden. Mich hat es ehrlich gesagt gewundert, dass das nicht schon während der Transferperiode größeres Thema war. Ich habe es zumindest erst jetzt mitbekommen, als dann auch über Barca die neuen Gehaltsobergrenzen einfach festgelegt wurden. Es hat mich ein bisschen gewundert, dass es da nicht den großen Ausverkaufsrun auf Sevilla gab.
Sie haben zumindest, wie gesagt, viele Spieler noch verkauft, haben aber trotzdem auch relativ viel geholt, auch kostenfrei und Sie müssen jetzt gucken, wie Sie das Ganze budgetieren wollen. Ich glaube, Sie haben jetzt einen Aufschub bekommen bis zur Winterpause, müssen mal gucken, was Sie an Sponsoren-Geld noch reinbekommen, was Sie sonst noch verkaufen können, um das irgendwie einigermaßen auszugleichen. Aber der Verfall ist natürlich heftig von letztes Jahr Champions League. Die Gruppenphase nicht geschafft, dadurch allein hast du ja schon ein ganz anderes Gehaltsbudget und dann sind Sie ja auch nur relativ knapp dem Abstieg entrun, letztes Jahr. Jetzt haben Sie eigentlich einen guten Trainer mit, Garcia Pimenta, der letztes Jahr bei Las Palmas sehr erfolgreich war, der aus der Barca-Schule kommt. Aber in Sevilla im Moment trainieren ist auch alles andere als eine einfache Aufgabe.
Schwieriger ist es dann nur Schatzmeister von Sevilla zu sein. Darüber werden wir glaube ich noch sprechen im weiteren Verlauf dieser Saison. Christian, über was sollen wir in der Serie A noch sprechen?
Ja, ich muss kurz noch mit dem Update starten. Also aus Rom sickert immer mehr durch. Wir haben ja dadurch, dass das erste Mittwoch passiert ist, quasi mit der Rossi. Nee, also es ist wirklich jetzt sickert so langsam durch, dass anscheinend da auf, weil Uli ja vorhin ein positives Beispiel von Ownership gebracht hat, dass womöglich die Entscheidung nach aufgrund von statistischen Basis getroffen wurde. Der Rossi hat wohl auch zum Abschied von allen Angestellten gesagt, diesmal kehre ich nicht mehr zurück. Also den haben sie jetzt komplett verloren. Also die Fritkens machen sich unfassbar angreifbar mit dieser Geschichte. Gestern vor dem Haus von Rossi haben sich noch viele Roma-Fans getroffen, um ihm Zuspruch zu geben. Also ich sage mal so, Mats Hummels hat es sich bis jetzt denken können, jetzt merkt er sehr schnell, dass Rom einer der emotionalsten Fußballstandorte in Europa ist. Also das nur so als kleines Update. Mein Moment ist, ein etwas längerer gezogener Moment, es ist Antonio Conte als Napoli. Der aktuelle Moment ist der, Napoli hat am Wochenende 4-0 auf Kaljari, auf Sardinen gewonnen in Kaljari. Und ich muss kurz die Klammer setzen, Napoli hat also vor dem Auftaktspieltag, also Antonio Conte, neuer Trainer, vor dem ersten Spieltag hat Conte auf der Pressekonferenz mal schnell klar gemacht, wie unzufrieden er damit ist, was auf dem Transfermarkt bisher passiert ist. Und dass hier gar nichts vorwärts geht. Und einen Tag später verliert Napoli 0 zu 3 bei Hellas Verona. Dementsprechend war die Laune, war die Lage. So, das war der Start. Und jetzt aber haben wir den vierten Spieltag. Und jetzt steht Napoli mit neun Punkten da. Sprich, sie haben alle anderen drei gewonnen. Stehen vor Juve, stehen vor Inter, vor allen anderen. Am Wochenende gab es einen 4-0. Ja, und die Herrschaften, die seitdem gekommen sind, funktionieren gleich. Am Wochenende lukaku-tor, Vorlage Quaratzkelia, Quaratzkelia-Tor, Vorlage lukaku, lukaku beim Debüt-Tor und Vorlage. lukaku, vielleicht zur Erinnerung, wenn es eine Verbindung zwischen Spieler und Trainer gibt in den letzten Jahren, dann würde ich lukaku und Conte da nennen. Also die zwei suchen und finden sich regelmäßig und haben auch schon ein paar Mal bewiesen, dass diese Symbiose ganz gut miteinander funktionieren kann. Also Napoli, am Ende waren es knapp um die 150 Millionen, die De Laurenti es noch ausgegeben hat. Conte hat mehr oder weniger alles bekommen, was er wollte. Neeres kam noch von Benfica, der jetzt auch dreimal von der Bank schon drei Vorlagen gebracht hat. Und jetzt wieder der Blick zu Uli und da bin ich wahnsinnig gespannt. Es sind ja auch noch die Herren McTominay und Gilmour da. Die arbeitet Conte jetzt so langsam ein im Training. Bis jetzt ist er klassisch mit seiner Dreierkette gestartet, so 3-4-2-1. Klassisch Conte, Quaratzkelia und Politana oder Neres so ein bisschen hängend hinter lukaku. Aber es heißt, was man aus Neapel hört und da freue ich mich sehr drauf. Er arbeitet eigentlich schon am 4-3-3 oder 4-3-2-1, um eben auch McTominay reinzubringen. Und ich muss sagen, da freue ich mich jetzt schon sehr. Ich glaube, dieser McTominay, ich glaube, das könnte ein Riesenfit für Napoli sein. Anguissa, Lobotka plus McTominay noch dazu. Die Torgefahr von McTominay muss ich nicht erzählen. Die erzählt euch Uli am besten. Also, ich glaube, da passiert sehr viel Richtiges. Ich habe es auch schon vor der Saison gesagt. Don't mess mit Antonio Conte, wenn er eine Mannschaft hat, die er auch gestalten kann. Und er und jetzt kommt es. Der große Spaß beginnt gerade diese Woche, während alle jetzt in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten in Italien unter der Woche quer durch Europa reisen, während Antonio Conte mit Napoli von Sonntag bis Sonntag arbeitet. Das heißt, nach dem Sonntag- oder Samstag-Spiel immer eine komplette Trainingswoche, weil sie nicht europäisch spielen. Dementsprechend wird Napoli lange dran bleiben. Ich glaube, Fabian hat ja vorhin schon mal einen Tipp abgegeben Richtung Saisonende. Ich gebe meinen auch ab. Wenn Napoli nicht in die Champions League zurückkehrt, dann weiß ich nicht, was passiert. Also Napoli und Conte werden dieses Jahr sehr gefährlich sein.
Ich gebe auch einen Tipp ab. Rasenfunk, Ligatour, September 2026. Antonio Conte ist im Sommer im Streit. Ich glaube, er ist weggegangen, weil er die Transfers nicht bekommen hat, die er wollte, obwohl er eigentlich alles bekommen hat, was er wollte.
Sehr gut möglich, aber eben in der Saison jetzt, ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt. Und gerade dieses McTominay und Gilmour auch. Bei Gilmour darf man nicht vergessen, den kennt er noch aus seiner Chelsea-Zeit. Da war er da schon wahnsinnig angetan. Den wollte er auch unbedingt. Was ich da vernommen habe, da hat Gilmour auch bei Brighton sehr viel dafür getan, dass es doch noch geklappt hat, dass er gehen konnte. Also das sind jetzt wirklich spannende Leute. Und nochmal, Conte kam Woche für Woche, von Montag bis Freitag oder von Montag bis Samstag, seine Systematik einarbeiten. Und wenn das sich dann jetzt auch noch von einer Dreierkette löst, ich glaube, das ist noch das letzte Rädchen, dann wären die richtig gefährlich. Oder sind sie ja im Prinzip ja schon. Und sorry, jetzt wirklich, allerletztes zum Absch… Ja, tut mir echt leid, aber das ist, weil es jetzt um Momente geht, da müssen sich jetzt vielleicht die Älteren da dazuschauen, die Jüngeren sagst vielleicht nichts mehr, aber Totto Schilacci ist gestern verstorben. Und ja, Totto Schilacci ist, ich weiß, die WM 1990 in Italien ist aus deutscher Sicht logischerweise für immer mit dem deutschen WM-Titel verbunden, völlig zu Recht auch, aber in Italien und ich glaube auch in vielen Ländern darüber hinaus ist die WM 1990 wirklich mit Totto Schilacci verbunden, der da mehr oder weniger aus nichts kam und ja, diese Heim-WM dann auch mit seinen Toren zu einer ganz ganz speziellen gemacht hat. Also wirklich eine spezielle Figur wurde jetzt vor einer Woche schon zum ersten Mal eingeliefert, da hieß es noch, ah, es wird wieder, aber jetzt ist er nochmal, hat sich verschlechtert und ist verstorben und wirklich Italiano Vantanto, Tosquilaci, das ist in Italien eine ganz emotionale Erinnerung.
Ist als Ersatzspieler zur WM mitgekommen, dann Torschützenkönig geworden. Ich habe mir eine sehr schöne Charakteratur gesehen, wo dieses Stäbchenmännchen, das Maskottchen der WM 90 trauernd an seinem Grab stand. Die fand ich sehr treffend. Also trifft, glaube ich, unsere Alterskohorte. Ja, ist klar. Absolut. Sehr gut, dass du es noch erwähnt hast. Hätte mich geärgert, wenn ich das vergessen hätte.
Ich hatte auch das Glück, einmal mit ihm zu sprechen, ein Interview zu führen. Und es ist wirklich eine dieser Sportfiguren, die einfach unglaublich mit einem großen Weltsportereignis verknüpft sind. Also ich glaube, da gibt es nicht so viele, die sozusagen, ja, die einfach so viel positiver Erinnerungen bei ganz, ganz vielen Menschen einfach weg.
Da finde ich auch so ein Gesicht, dass wenn du einmal gesehen hast, das vergisst du nicht mehr.
Nee, absolut.
Es gibt so Menschen, wo ich denke, boah.
Ja, definitiv. Und hat er mit Robby Baggio damals auch im Sturm zusammen gespielt und mein Baggio ist sowas wie Fußballgott in Italien und dann dieser Combo aus Baggio plus Gellace, der aus dem Nichts kam und Baggio hat jetzt auch ganz emotionale Worte gefunden zum Abschied. Baggio ist ja eigentlich einer, der nicht mehr in der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet, das sich komplett zurückzieht und gemeint, ja Toto, du hast mich auch diesmal überrascht, so auf dem Spielfeld. Also ja, wie gesagt, wirklich eine emotionale, italienische Fußballgeschichte.
Ja, danke, dass du es noch erwähnt hast. Und dann haben wir noch einen Moment aus der Premier League. Uli.
Ich möchte es nicht zu morbide machen, deswegen jubel ich da hinunter. Aber trotzdem sei das einmal erwähnt. Aston Villa ist für alle, die diesem Club anhängen, glaube ich wahnsinnig wichtig gewesen. Er hat in dieser Woche Champions League gespielt, erstmals nach 41 Jahren. Und in genau dieser Woche, in der sie spielen, nämlich am Montag, verstirbt einer aus dem Siegerteam von 82, nämlich Gary Shaw, der bis dato die meisten Tore innerhalb einer Europapokalsaison geschossen hat. Das ist manchmal so bittersüß, wenn solche Momente dann zeitlich auch so aufeinander fallen. Weil auf der einen Seite gedenkt man einen der ganz Großen in diesem Verein, in dem wahrscheinlich größten Team des ersten Villa hatte. Und auf der anderen Seite ist dann die neue Generation da, die sich das total erarbeitet haben. Auch da mit vernünftigen Besitzern, die schon Geld reinpulvern, aber einen Trainer machen lassen. Und es ist denen, glaube ich, in Birmingham wahnsinnig wichtig, dass sie endlich wieder da sind, wo sie denken, dass sie hingehören nicht, in Anführungszeichen, nur in der Conference League, sondern ganz oben in der Champions League. Aber damit wir nicht komplett traurig rausgehen aus der Sache, Most Random Transfer Ever. Das ist wirklich ein Moment, der seit zwei Tagen bei mir nachhalt. Anthony Martial ist ohne Witz zu IK Arthéen gegangen. Wir leben einfach doch im Fußballmanager. Es können Dinge passieren, die können nicht passieren. Das ist der Golden Boy von Joel Glazer, den er mit Pelé verglichen hat, als er ihn geholt hat. Er hat ihm diesen völlig irren Deal gegeben, der bis jetzt in den Sommer reinging. Jetzt haben sie die Nummern gewechselt und haben die Schlösser wahrscheinlich ausgetauscht, damit er bloß nicht mehr an den Fuß der Inkerin reinsetzt. Einfach Wahnsinn.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Da hast du mich jetzt blank erwischt. Ja, so ist es. Das ist Fußball. Das ist einfach Fußball. Das ist Fußball. Nicht nur der Ausgleich in der 91. Minute oder die Geräte, die zur Notbremse wird, sondern auch das ist Fußball. Das ist Business-Fußball. Ihr 4. Es hat große Freude gemacht, mit euch zu sprechen. Herzlichen Dank an Daniel Zander von Oranifußball, an Fabian Pakulat, an Christian Bernhardt und an Uli Hebel. Ich werde alles verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Ich werde auch noch zwei Nachrufe verlinken auf Tutu Skilaci und Gary Schorr. Dann könnt ihr, wenn ihr wollt, da auch noch weiterlesen. Herzlichen Dank euch, Fieren, dass ihr mit dabei wart bei dieser ersten Ligatour dieser Saison. Danke euch. Da müsst ihr jetzt alle sagen, danke, lieber Max. Die alten Mechanismen, die müssen noch reinkommen. Die neuen Mechanismen sind auch, dass die Hörern und Töre uns bitte weiter unterstützen. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und in dieser Folge danke ich Viva La Ben, Peter, Uli Klümper, Hiro Li und Hendrik HP7. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und dann bewertet uns auch sehr gerne bei der Podcastplattform Eure Wahl und gebt uns Feedback auf dieses Format. Freuen wir uns auch sehr drüber. Und ansonsten bleibt gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk gewogen und bis bald. Macht's gut.
Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von Euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.